you know because Elon Musk is the main
character now I guess every every news
stories about him but it's probably
because he took over the narrative
machine and they have nothing to do
they're trapped these journalists are
trapped in elon's box where he
determines what they can or can't say
and for the most part he's allowing Free
Speech it's a coffee maker Luke
maker
so it's really funny because we got a
couple different reports about how these
these Twitter Roddy journalists are
desperately trying to get off Twitter
but can't and they keep coming back and
the big news with Twitter Elon has
banned Elon Jett an account that was
tracking his private jet and he said
that anybody who's posting real-time
information about someone's location is
doxing them
I actually agree yeah I I I think Elon
in the past probably didn't think it was
that big of a deal until his life was
very much at risk and then he was like
okay now this is becoming a problem
here's the thing the kid who who posts
these uh these tweets about where elon's
jet is he's still doing it on other
places a website Instagram Facebook so
Elon can't really do anything about it
but I get the point he's trying to make
so we'll talk about that plus Donald
Trump says he has a major announcement
to make tomorrow I suppose we'll see
what that is and then there's a whole
bunch of uh silly culture War stuff we
got a viral video from The Washington
Post where masked employees The
Washington Post no one's probably no
one's surprised by that are complaining
that they're about to get laid off
because the Washington Post is shrinking
they're losing subscribers Jeff Bezos
woke media machine is failing
it started my friends however head over
to eat right and feelwell.com and pick
up your keto Elevate from BioTrust C8
MCT oil powder that is medium chain
triglyceride power powder basically fat
I like mixing it in my coffee makes a
little creamy creamy and delicious they
say and uh well about a year ago I cut
out sugars for the most part dropping
down from a couple hundred carbs per day
to like 20 and 30 and now I usually
maintain underneath under like 30 to 40
and I I lost a ton of weight so head
over to eat right and feelwell.com and
you can get what do we got 51 off a
60-day money-back guarantee keto Elevate
provides your body only C8 the most
ketogenic medium chain triglyceride
providing energy providing support for
energy levels healthy appetite
Management Mental Clarity and focus
athletic performance you get five grams
of MCT per scoop it's my personal
favorite you'll get free shipping on
every order and for every order today
BioTrust will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kidhungry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
bio trust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you'll get free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order so
again head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com shout out bio
trust thank you for sponsoring the show
and also head over to timcast.com become
a member we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show as we always do up
tonight at about 11 p.m so head over the
web head over to the website click join
us and then you can become a member and
I want to give a special shout out to
timcast's good friend Mr bocus who is
seen here in the center square of our
little Talent roster of course we've got
Roberto Jr chilling as well but we very
much love our our animal friends and Mr
bocus as many of you may be aware is
very very sick he's terminally ill we
don't know much time he has left but I
really do appreciate all of the
well-wishers joining us tonight after
you smash that like button subscribe to
the channel share the share with your
friends is from America First legal Gene
Hamilton thanks Tim thanks for having me
on yeah who are you what do you do so
Tim I'm uh a title is Vice President
general counsel of America First legal
um but look we are a freedom fighting
organization we are here to stop the
woke Insanity of the Biden
administration of the woke left and to
fight for the rights of all Americans so
that's that's really kind of who we are
what we do we've been involved in a lot
of the stuff lately in terms of this big
Tech censorship and collaboration with
the government uh stopping race-based
programs that discriminate against
Americans based on the color of their
skin you name the issue and we're we're
getting involved in it these days right
on you guys recently had there was a big
Revelation the lawsuits you're involved
in have exposed government collusion
with big Tech platforms right I mean
look it's it's one of several kind of
channels that are going on at the same
time right which is uh whether that's
the hunter Biden or the Twitter files
with the with the laptop stuff that
elon's been exposing whether it's this
Missouri lawsuit that Eric Schmidt's
been leading or whether it's our own
investigative work that we've been doing
for uh a number of months now producing
stuff to show hey look like there were
actually back Channel Communications the
government actors were making with
Twitter with Facebook where they had
channels that they were able to report
what they deemed as misinformation or
disinformation and get it get it taken
down by the platforms which should be
shocking to everybody but that's just an
example of one of the things that we've
been doing considering as I mentioned
Elon Musk is basically the main
character uh we're gonna get into all
this stuff so thanks for joining us we
got Luke radkowski hanging out yep Gene
said he's going to be bailing us out of
the gulags so thank you in advance I
really appreciate that my name is Lou
gradowski of we are change.org today I'm
wearing a t-shirt that we just designed
last week that says things I'll never
see in my life and of course it has a
flying pig on it it has a unicorn on it
it has a dinosaur on it and of course it
has the Epstein Maxwell Client List that
you will never see because the
government is very corrupt if you like
this shirt and the larger messaging
behind it you could get it on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because you
do that's why I'm here thank you so much
for having me hi everyone Ian crosland
here Ian crossland.net uh if you follow
me on any social media it's networks you
want to it's good to see a gene and I'm
looking forward to going deep on this as
we've been talking about this a lot the
last couple weeks and I'm glad to see
that you've been so heavily involved
sounds great
and we also have surge yes I'm back I'm
back guys uh ready for the show to be a
good one today
all right we're gonna get started with
the the more serious news that Elon Musk
actually just dropped and there's some
uh news related to this Elon said any
account doxing real-time location info
of anyone will be suspended as it is a
physical safety violation this includes
posting links to sites with real-time
location info posting locations someone
traveled to on a slightly delayed basis
isn't a safety problem so it's okay so
the big story today that's trending like
crazy is Elon Jet and all of these
leftists are like I can't believe Elon
banned Elon jet he said he believed in
free speech Free Speech means you can
share public information Elon just
posted this only uh about 20 minutes ago
last night a car carrying Lil X in La
was followed by a crazy stalker thinking
it was me who later blocked the car from
moving and climbed onto the hood legal
action is being taken against Sweeney
and organizations who supported harm to
my family
so this is crazy here's the story from
CNN
Twitter suspense account that tracked
musk's private jet despite Billionaire's
Free Speech pledge you know Free Speech
pledge they say Twitter uh on Wednesday
suspended an account that tracked the
location of his jet despite his
commitment of free speech blah blah blah
Twitter later restored the Elon jet
account Wednesday evening after the
company posted a new set of edicts that
appeared to be designed specifically to
justify the removal of the jet tracking
account the move comes after musk has
reinstated previous Twitter rule breaker
rule Breakers the Elon jet account run
by Jack Sweeney a 20 year old Florida
College student used publicly available
flight tracking information to build a
Twitter bot that tweeted every time
musk's Gulf Stream took off and landed
at an airport the last post from the
account prior to the suspension showed
musk's jet taking off from Oakland
California on Monday and landing in Los
Angeles 48 minutes later
Sweeney woke up Wednesday morning with a
message from Twitter saying he'd been
banned now here's what I'm wondering was
this it
was it actually Lil X flying on the
plane and then a lunatic seeing the
information shows up starts harassing
Lil X and then I mean this is not this
is not a play that elon's on so this
this this goes beyond just uh doxing
elon's jet this wasn't about Elon this
is a private jet which can be used by
many people can be rented out can be
commissioned and because of that very
serious uh harm nearly came to an
individual I also want to mention that
one story where what was it that rapper
you mentioned this before the show serge
that rapper who was like chilling with
his girlfriend and she posted a picture
of his burger oh yeah pnb Rock that's
right Chicken and Waffles chicken and
waffles correct in South uh South
Central L.A and then someone walked up
and just shot and killed him yeah taking
it for his uh he's famous for his chains
wearing a lot of chains around him and
someone just felt like it was their time
to take them yeah so what do you guys
think I kind of agree with this policy I
think you should not be doxing doxing is
Real Time exposing you know someone's
personal information or private
information I guess you would call it
not like what like what hair color even
things like that like what their name is
what their address is what their phone
number is what they look like those kind
of data in real time to people you don't
know is a form of doxing but the thing
is elon's got to specify what real time
means because is it five minutes ago is
that still considered real times at nine
minutes ago like when is it now no
longer real time we were we were talking
about this uh Ian broads up before the
show when we went to New York to check
out the ads we put up in Times Square
Ian took some pictures we're gonna post
them and I was like wait just wait a few
minutes wait yeah I waited like 20
minutes we changed locations before I
put the picture up because we were
standing right where I took the picture
and that was a smart move you never know
real time you know well considering that
rapper store the chicken and waffles
yeah seriously makes a lot of sense
don't dangle your gems in front of the
hungry and poor
yeah don't show unnecessary data you
don't don't don't leave things in plain
sight in your car when you go in to the
store you know it's valuable it's a good
point but it was like the analogy was
very esoteric yeah it's like most people
don't have gems to dangle but right but
Ian's got a big pile in front of them so
like like don't leave your phone and
play in sight in your car when you get
out and go into the store stuff like
that don't tempt Faith yeah right don't
don't bring all your fancy dye to a game
shop unless you want people to to lust
for them and I think doxing is a form of
tempting fate you're like saying it you
know I'm not saying to do anything but
here's the in phone case you want to
kind of thing yeah look I I I'm in total
agreement with you guys it's the right
policy it's the right call I mean when
folks physical safety is that issue it's
a totally different ball game and mind
you the same critics who are calling you
know complaining about this saying Oh Mr
free speech whatever are the same a lot
of the same folks who are probably
saying misinformation or disinformation
during the pandemic were forms of
violence or that they were threatening
they needed to be taken down they've
lost their they've lost their Baseline
of reality and what's actually a threat
to people and what's not and your
physical location the harm the the
safety of your family and in yourself is
Paramount and so that's absolutely
something that needs to be monitored but
you know misinformation disinformation
it's
ridiculous yet they were take they were
more than happy to cheer that on yeah
the word violence has been taken away
out of context and blown out proportion
like it's calling someone a name even if
it's a nasty name is not violent right
it's not right you know a
and we need to really really be honest
about what real violence is
uh I think in order to use that term
effectively well there's a lot of other
things happening here that are worth
considering uh but there's also some
people reporting that the Elon jet
Instagram account is also being banned
on Twitter and is being prevented from
people uh giving the ability of sharing
that URL uh just a couple days ago Elon
Musk said that he's not going to be
doing any open air car parades anytime
soon as of course A lot of people are
saying that he might be getting Epstein
as it's fair to say that orange man bad
has been replaced with spaceship man bad
and right now the media top uh top level
lawyers a lot of powerful politicians a
lot of intelligence agencies aren't
really happy with him and are putting a
lot of pressure on him to the point
where there's even lawyers right now
going through his application for
citizenship in the United States seeing
if he made a mistake seeing if he lied
so they could try to renounce his U.S
citizenship which is crazy that's not
true is it I I believe so some some
random woman tweeted that and everyone
was just like why wouldn't it be true
especially with how how much they're
grasping for the straws when it comes to
attacking him I wouldn't be surprised if
this was true I wouldn't either but some
random leftist propaganda account
claiming that they're trying to revoke
Elon citizenship is very different from
a news report at the very least like you
know we got a video of The Washington
Post people getting laid off and
freaking out and I tweeted you know
what's that word for when you derive
pleasure from the suffering of your
enemies and uh so we get it we get it
shot him for it but um I still would be
like some random blue check saying it
versus an organization putting their
weight behind it not like I trust them a
whole lot they'll probably twist and lie
about it but there's got to be some
evidence
well I I you know I think I think you're
right
um and uh but at the same time when we
look at all the high-level pressure
tactics that are going against Elon it
wouldn't surprise me if people are doing
this not putting their face behind it
yet because it's more about sending a
threat it's more about trying to harass
someone it's more about trying to
intimidate someone and I think that's
why this news was shared uh so widely
today and talked about as significantly
as it was because I I I truly do see uh
them grasping at the straws here and
trying to figure out any reason to try
to get him and try to stop him from
doing what he's doing because as we
mentioned here many times on this show
he's changing the game here he's
creating a situation where people are
finally able to speak freely this
changes everything powerful people the
only thing that they have is the
consensus is the only thing that they
have is people's ignorance especially
when they commit all these crimes
against populations so when you have a
man promising to get rid of all of that
that's a huge threat against them and
this is why I think he's taking his
safety more seriously than ever before I
hope Elon if you're listening you gotta
if you're gonna subvert the Empire you
got to do it subtly if you tell them
your plans before you do it that's what
JFK kept doing kept telling him that
he's going to disband the CA and the CIA
and and then they you know come out they
can stop you if you let if they know
what you're gonna do I don't so subtlety
and decentralization I don't think he's
revealed his plan I I I kind of feel
like there's there's a couple memes
going around about how Elon is very much
in line with the the world economic
Forum on many many issues uh Ubi being
one of them that he's got Tesla
factories in China and that he's praised
the Chinese Communist Party in the past
you know look the dude may agree with us
on some key issues like Free Speech but
I don't think he agrees with us on a lot
of issues you know I got a uh uh I saw
on YouTube Hassan uh [ __ ] the leftist
made a video called Tim Poole confronts
Elon Musk where he actually says it's an
unironic like of a tweet from Tim Poole
because I tweeted out that that gag
where I said you know I used to think
neuro link was scary and dangerous but
then Elon bought Twitter and agreed with
me ideologically now I think neuralink
is great and want to have my brain
plugged into the machine and so he was
like yeah great but then he got he got
mad at me because I said look I'm
screwing around neural link is great you
know but the putting in your brain
interface stuff is something else he
didn't like that but I think there is
something to it when
leftists like that would agree like hey
hey the neural link brain stuff is
probably over the line you know that we
don't we don't we don't want to go there
so I'm like well if that's the unifying
thing and he actually liked to tweet for
me bro I agree you know I can understand
if someone's paralyzed they want neural
link they'll ask for it I don't like the
idea that elon's outright said the goal
of it is human one-to-one AI interfacing
which in my view
erases Humanity but I think that AI is
going to erase Humanity anyway and that
we're probably yeah we're evolving into
some technocratic you know machine first
Society it seems like where it's
inevitably we might Branch off and have
still like you know ludite humans that
don't want they want to live in the
jungle and be away from electricity but
like we're not going to be in this Homo
Sapien form forever as the dominant
species on Earth so I think that we are
becoming I mean we're already kind of
Cyborg and I love the idea of being able
to type with my thoughts and being able
to communicate with my thoughts because
I think way faster than my hands can
type it's true but see that's what you
think is going to happen and what's
really going to happen is you're gonna
you know Phil Phil made a really really
great point about this filibonti last
night he said you get the neuraling they
don't tell you to do anything what
happens is you'll go out and you'll do
something you'll you'll buy a McDonald's
cheeseburger and the neural link
instantly will give you the tiniest
little dopamine hit you won't know why
but you'll just enjoy yourself and over
time those micro hits of dopamine will
start pushing you in a specific
Direction and shaping you into the
person you never chose to be and you
won't even realize you were manipulated
into being a puppet yeah if the code and
the algorithms are not free of the
neural net everything has to be
transparent you need to know why it's
feeding you what dopamine rushes when
what levels and ideally you're setting
those levels yourself
um it will be complete Annihilation for
the species if it is not open source and
free software you need complete
transparency with a technology like this
it's like I mean in a way I was gonna
say it's like running water but we
really don't know what's coming out of
our tap water either so if you think
hacking a a computer network is valuable
wait till you can hack a person
like there already is social engineering
a field of you know hacker culture where
people manipulate people but imagine
being able to pull up a keyboard knowing
the code because it's open source then
governments develop exploits there would
be open source patching of these of
these security issues too don't get me
wrong but you're going to see Zero day
attacks you're going to be sitting in
your room and you're going to be like
all right let's do the anti-government
subversive show oh my brain's exploding
and then just oh no he got hacked it was
routed through a bunch of ips we can't
figure out who did it you could do it so
like it automatically shuts down if
there's outside interference
um how would it how everything
everything is exploitable so as long as
there's any kind of read write
capabilities someone will find a way to
go into your brain and just mess you up
yeah you thought computer viruses were
bad imagine that in your head when your
computer is is your brain so uh there's
a lot of potential for a lot of things
going wrong here and uh I think
skepticism is our best friend moving
forward so so we have all of these uh
you know Twitter leftists freaking out
they're screaming you know Elon Musk is
doxing people I thought he believed in
free speech and my response is kind of
just like I don't care what you think
because you never agree with free speech
in the first place so get off your high
horse No One Believes you but you know
Elon pointed out that someone basically
attacked Little X who was like I guess
using his plane I'm not sure if that's
what it was but we have this story which
I think is absolutely fascinating and on
point Nancy mace left-wing activist she
exposed for extremist tweets with
snowflake Emoji oh my oh my
so here's what happens
a bunch of these uh woke leftists fake
like fake news Liars they make fake
posts all day and night they lie about
everything because they are psychotic
cultists they're evil people
they're being uh they're testified
before Congress and Nancy mace asks do
you think rhetoric online is bad and
they'll say yes you think it leads to
violence yes then she pulls up this
tweet from Alejandra Caraballo who
called for the public accosting of
Supreme Court Justices
she then mentions you know someone went
and tried to kill Brett Kavanaugh and
it's it's an epic roast this person
carbio is like I need to clarify you
that's not actually what I said and
she's like it's right here you said it
and boom made your SmackDown
when these people come out and they get
angry at Elon and they're like I thought
you were going to protect free speech
and eon's like dude don't share the
location of my jet these are people who
are trying to use our good faith against
us that we would believe in free speech
they want to justify the sharing of
elon's real-time location data okay
that's scary and it says to me they want
him dead
I know it's a meme where like these
leftists will be like they want you dead
that's it that's the Republican party
but like if they're actively calling for
violence if they've gone and thrown
molotovs into police vehicles and smash
windows and quite literally killed
dozens of people in the May uh George
Floyd riots and then Elon Musk is like
you know for safety reasons I won't be
doing public events and we're gonna shut
down real-time location sharing and then
they go oh no oh oh geez our Free Speech
oh oh what are you doing yeah no they
just want him hurt boxing people on the
internet's Free Speech anyway right it
is it is I mean it's free speech under
the US Constitution in in the colloquial
sense of telephones and like you could
put a piece of paper on a telephone pole
that showed a guy's face with his
address that was legal but now that we
have the Internet it's another realm of
of function and this kind of thing is
not it's not like benefiting Society to
dox people so I don't see why we support
it as a form of free speech I mean I
guess it's a challenge it is free speech
you're allowed to say so and so lives
here it's it we had a phone book you
know before you growing up there's the
White Pages you can Google search
someone's address it's very very easy
so it's tough to justify when on social
media they say don't post someone's
address when you can just Google it and
see it if you want to however I still do
agree there's there's no idea expressed
in Sharing someone's physical location
there's probably some exemptions to this
like if someone was at like the Bohemian
Grove or something in real time and
you're like they're here now look so I
have to wonder if there's an a potential
negative downside to this if if let's
say for instance Bill Gates is in real
time at Epstein Island and someone
shares that can they get banned or is
Elon going to be alive no no it's okay
you're exposing him being absenting I
know I think he's going to be like
real-time location sharing is wrong
erase that
what do you think look
I just keep coming back to the
fundamental point that your personal
physical safety and the safety
especially of your kids of your family
is one of the most important things that
we've lost sight of um amongst all of
this and so anything that's going to
again this is a this this is a private
platform
um that to make it so that at least it
makes it a little bit harder for someone
to actually find out where you are when
there's real threats against someone
who's high profile like that makes a ton
of sense you know again it's you just go
back and you juxtapose it against the
stuff that they actually were trying to
take down the things that they were
trying to flag is misinformation
disinformation false information in in
their eyes was totally fine and
acceptable but something that's actually
going to physically threaten somebody or
their family to say that that's somehow
wrong is is is just lacks common sense
it's setting everything else aside yeah
I think we also have to be careful to
also respect
um journalism here because I I could see
this being used to hurt journalism
especially when it comes to individuals
like Bill Clinton meeting the people
that were investigating him on the
tarmac uh with the with the head of the
DNC like someone going to the Bilderberg
meeting some prominent individuals going
and colluding with corporate individuals
or like the prime minister of New
Zealand going to Blackrock I think those
are all newsworthy events how do we
cover them without also compromising
people's safety how do we cover them
without being censored online I think
those are bigger questions that I I'm
kind of left here after all this I think
you just don't want to dox them in real
time like if someone goes if I'm
reporting if I'm doing a live stream
outside of the Bilderberg meeting right
and then Klaus Schwab or let's just say
Eric Schmidt you know walks down the
street which has happened to me I go up
to him I'm like hey Eric Schmidt what
are you doing here is that considered
something that will get me punished or
banned I I hope not you know it raises
some questions here
that I think should be answered yeah
because it's legal to publicly to record
someone in public yeah because it is in
the public interest
is your politician meeting with the
corporate heads uh your politician
meeting with secret groups of shadowy
Elites behind closed doors making
decisions for the general public is
something that is important but there
are also a lot of crazy people out there
that do want to hurt people and that's
out of your control how do you mitigate
the dangers with with actual reporting I
don't know I don't have that answer
um but you know I think the law says one
thing right now right like what what's
what's the legal basis for for all of
this
well I mean look on Twitter again it's
it's a private platform and so Elon Musk
can make whatever rules he wants for his
private platform but I think it's I
think there's a difference there's a
difference between CNN or fox or
whomever interviewing some Senator
standing in front of the Capitol
building that's something that's not
going to attract a crazy that's not
something that's not going to make it
that much easier for some Rando to
follow that person to plot things out
it's a totally different deal if you've
got like a flight tracker that's got
your real-time location I mean would we
be okay with a GPS device that someone
put on your car
right and then they mapped it and then
anyone in the world could know exactly
where your car was at any point in time
and someone created a Twitter bot that
was reporting on your location I I mean
I don't think so no I don't think that
would be good I'm just I'm finding it
all funny because the left screams about
stochastic terrorism
where it's the the old concept oh won't
someone rid me of this priest they're
like you know uh China right chick lives
of tick tock is a stochastic terrorist
who you know incites indirectly all of
this hatred so that people know to go do
these things it's like okay shut up like
you're literally calling for violence
and then demanding we get to know
exactly where Elon Musk is right come on
as they also say that words are violent
as they're telling everyone that having
a scientific debate on a procedure
that's been rushed through without any
long-term studies even just questioning
that is dangerous and it's going to lead
to murder I mean these are very
nonsensical very emotionally driven
individuals that clearly are there
serving an agenda rather than trying to
have an honest conversations about what
is right about our rights and and about
what we should have is sacred and that
is our ability to to say what we want as
long as we're not hurting anyone who
decides how people get hurt again that's
up in the air here and I'm left with
that question I don't have an answer to
it myself maybe if you're if you're
doxing someone it's in a secure location
like you said someone went into a
building then maybe that's less
dangerous than if you're docking someone
that's out on the street out in the open
maybe that there's something there what
is what does Elon think it's going to
happen once we're all neural linked you
you and and assume assume it's
decentralized assume it's centralized
there's there's no way if you increase
the speed of information tenfold 100
fold hooking people's brains right to
the machine everyone will know where
everyone is all the time and there's no
there's no blocking that information you
can't do it right and then I would think
there would be huge amounts of rapidly
escalating violence that would then
settle and then you would have a sense
of calm but then you would know who was
going to be violent before they were
violent so you could stop them and then
you're in pre-crime which is like
minority minority report where they're
arresting people that haven't even done
anything yet so I don't like that maybe
I mean depending on where we go with
neuralink what might happen is the AI
will start track it'll track everyone's
brain patterns and then it will be like
there's a
97.3 percent of the time when there's a
mass shooting the brain patterns look
like this in this part of the brain
within an hour of the attack and then
all of a sudden some dudes walking down
the street and you know the the
pre-crime unit comes and grabs them and
cuffs them and says you're about to
commit a crime we could tell by tracking
your brain they'll do that and then
they'll go to the guy's trunk and
they'll find all these guns and we see
it's proof that we can do it and then I
could see them starting like an entire
you know a sector of the government as
pre-crime and then all of a sudden it's
work it's not working sometimes they're
getting people but it's all for your
safety it's all for your health it's all
for the greater good Ian for the for the
for the common man yes for the
collective live in the Pod eat the bugs
and plug into the New Orleans I think
we're better off and it will benefit
society and space and reality better as
a borg unit or as a bunch of defined
benefit like you know increase
Prosperity growth you know diminish
um you know entropy if you followed Star
Trek stuff you know there was a board
Queen who was a centralized unit yeah
and the the Borg Queen was like an
independent mind that controlled the
whole network of its benefit maybe a
decentralized borg I've never seen a
fantasy decentralized Borg unit that
might work better I think it's bad
either way benefit is is it's an opinion
I guess but some people probably think
that all humans Network together is a
good thing and they want to Borg that
just seems like you're dead it seems
like every individual human dies at that
moment and then what you end up with is
this Collective Hive of noise of of no
merit it's just a buzz it's just a
machine
I think individuality is is beautiful I
think each little unique unique
snowflake you know is something of value
so that's what's worrying to me about
this idea of of norlink in the long run
but I don't know whatever we'll see
where we go huh how about that that's
weird yeah that's a ghost ghost in the
show basically a lot of the stuff is
what I reminisce immediately but but at
least in Ghost in the Shell for those
that are familiar anime and manga like
you're an individual yeah they cyberize
your brain with Nanobots and then you
can interface with computers and stuff
correct but the reality of what would
happen as we're already seeing with
Twitter is that we'd become a hive like
we're already turning into that just
because we have cell phones as it is
which is creepy or do you think you'll
get the neural net at any point Gene
you know look I I who knows probably not
I'm I'm much more of an individualist
um myself I don't like the idea of any
kind of machine planted in me but that's
me
um so you know look but I think the
point Timmy just made which is you see
the way right now
the the spheres of influence and the
power centers who have been using social
media and who have been using these
Avenues of communication in the media
have already formed a lot of this group
think in our society and we see the
dangers that are associated with that
when we have things like certain certain
people are determining what's true and
what's false and anything else is
censored in the shutdown and you're not
allowed you're not allowed to say
anything and we're already you know you
already see some of that today in a way
that you didn't see 10 20 30 years ago
at all and that's just based on our you
know modern modern communication and in
technology and social media
we go from like haha we're gonna make
fun of these you know woke people on
social media now we're like well we're
gonna plug ourselves into the brain turn
into a machine and the world ends Let's
uh let's jump to this this clip we have
this uh this tweet this tweet from clay
Travis The Washington Post which has
lost 500 000 subscribers in the past
year has announced layoffs are coming to
the paper the meeting didn't go well oh
let's play the meeting for you
look at look at they're wearing masks
people's jobs are they going to be
treated like the magazine staffers they
will have we'll have more information as
we move forward thank you very much
as these people wear masks and wine
about what are you going to do to
protect people's jobs I uh we're talking
about neurolink and I'm like these
people will sign up day one that's and I
think I wonder if Elon knows that
he looks at these people and he was like
these people would put masks on their
asses if they were told to do it by the
government they're going to get the
neural link when we tell them to do it
they got the apps the mobile apps they
got the ID cards they all did it who
didn't
well it's the conservatives the
Libertarians it's the anarchists it's
the right whatever they want to call it
these are the people who are like nah
how do you convince them to do it you
got to win them over that was the point
of the tweet I was making basically like
as if this is going to happen people
these people government's going to come
out and say oh you know as a pandemic
and there's Terror so you got to get the
chip once you get the chip then you can
go to your Starbucks
but people like us we're gonna be like
nah I don't need Starbucks I think they
would also really love those Chinese
covet tests that they're applying to
people up there you know what uh but but
I asked but I I do believe that there is
going to be a larger Financial Reckoning
I I think Elon is trying to um uh do as
many things fiscally responsible at
Twitter right now because I think he
sees the storm is coming especially
financially that is going to be
correlated with centralized forces
pushing a Ubi pushing Central Bank
digital currencies pushing for a
solution that of course is going to
greatly benefit them and give them more
power over everyone else so I think
these layoffs are just more layoffs to
come already there was so much uh
layoffs in the tech industry when it
came to Amazon when it came to Facebook
when it came to Twitter these are not
accidental layoffs these are layoffs in
anticipation of the larger Financial
Market being turned upside down because
the last three years we prioritized
safety shutting down small mom and
businesses over of course Walmart Costco
and all these other billionaires that
got richer more than they ever did
before in their entire human history
when we look at this larger transfer of
wealth it was a lot of money when we
look at how much money the US federal
reserve prints it's a lot of money
there's going to be ramifications for
that I think this is the beginning sign
of a lot of other businesses that are
going to be laying people off in droves
to come the next few weeks and months
what do you think financially Gene
What's Happening Here I I think you I
think almost everything you said is is I
would agree with 100 and we we are
facing a financial Reckoning we're
because it's not it's not just issues
like this but it's government with with
the printing money with spending money
on just anything just you know dealing
it out like it's candy at Halloween is
not a good way to run your Society so
there is a reckoning that's coming I I
don't know what the the uh influence
with the Washington Post though uh with
this with this particular video I mean
it it sounds like they've lost
subscribers from what I understand yeah
half a million I think half a million
that's a ton of folks that's a ton of
people but look I mean you just you
can't you can't run a business if you
lose half a million subscribers you
can't continue to end so hopefully it's
a lesson that you know hey maybe maybe
they could actually try to report on
some things a little bit more of a
balanced Direction but they're not going
to take that lesson these workers are
going to vote communist in two seconds
right yeah Washington Post is going to
shut down or they're going to get fired
and they're going to say but our jobs
are essential what do we do I know let's
vote for the government to nationalize
The Washington Post that's a good idea
then our jobs will be secured what they
leave out of those ideas is that it's
basically our jobs are secured by
forcing other people to make food for us
at gunpoint doesn't the CIA have enough
black budget money to finance The
Washington Post aren't they already
doing it I mean come on let's be real
here when when their reporting is just
based on Anonymous Intel sources all the
time you would think the CIA would throw
them a few bucks well come on CIA you
could do a little bit better Amazon also
Jeff Bezos has a lot of connections with
the CIA so just something to think about
here but but this is a big problem here
because Vice news is also reporting that
there's going to be layoffs there's
going to be restrictions at the company
look at just what happened to CNN it
doesn't pay to be a shill so that's a
big Learning lesson from all the
corporate media that's that's dealing
with a big Reckoning as Independent
Media I mean you're doing good I'm doing
good we're growing yeah
if we had anywhere near half a million
subscribers that would be just
absolutely Bonkers Game Changer like I
mean absolutely five I just do the math
500 000 members and we and it's 10 bucks
a month to be a member at timcast.com
yeah you're talking 60 million dollars a
year at that point I'm that's a crazy
amount of cash to be dealing with you
could hire thousands of people you could
you could you could just basically gut
all of your competition and higher up
their their employees if you had that
that much money these are spoiled brats
that are getting the diamond pacifier
slapped out of their mouths okay that's
what's happening here nothing else more
I got a question so you know Elon he
rolled out the new color verification
and uh if you pull this up we got the
Washington Post they get a yellow badge
and they say that you know yellow means
business and I'm like I I could not but
notice that all of the news outlets are
yellow
is that a is that was that on purpose is
Elon Musk behind the scenes laughing and
mocking them yellow journalism it's a
reference to just garbage you know
garbage in yellow bellies uh stocks and
Hammer had a very interesting tweet
highlighting the which one
no no no he he said that this is the
universal symbol for propaganda and
sensationalism and well he's not wrong
but the post-millennial I think is
yellow yeah and uh it's just you know I
don't think it they just made news
organizations yellow I just think that's
funny it's like wink wink nudge nudge I
like it when I'm looking at the
Washington Post struggling right now I
think what's happening is these old
things that used to rely on text because
that was all they had in the 1960s and
70s and 80s and stuff like that you
didn't have internet video and it was
very expensive to have a TV network
they're still relying on this lame-ass
text like text is fine for what it is
which is to get a piece of data across
it there's no emotional value so when
you're trying to explain emotions use
internet video you need to be hiring
people to be making internet videos cut
down on your overhead wait they can be
working from home man stop giving them
tips and advice
they don't need the help the employees I
care about their shields for the CIA
don't give them advice either please I
want you to to understand what's going
on with the old Guard versus a new guard
and I'll use a very simple analogy I
want you to imagine a large waffle got a
big waffle on your plate with all the
little nooks and crannies is that what
they're called the holes in the waffles
because I remember the echo commercial
and so you know what this podcast is is
delicious organic fresh maple syrup
maybe from Vermont and as it is poured
over that waffle it gets into all those
little nooks and crannies along with the
butter and it's perfect every bite what
the Old Guard media is is like taking a
sheet of paper and placing it on top of
the waffle it doesn't get into the
cracks my point is
the reason why these kinds of shows in
this kind of news is taking off taking
off is because we don't just say
headline as Roe v Wade repeal looms
video game industry stays silent what we
do is we expand upon that we get in
depth with it we all talk about we
bounce ideas around them we ask the
audience talk about it so what I mean by
filling all the nooks and crannies is
we're trying to hit every crevice every
point that we can whereas with the
Washington Post does they don't even
they don't even give you a blanket view
they don't even cover the waffle they
they give you this Twisted line of
butter that goes in a random Direction
and you're like that's it what is this
it's not even the real story
they're selectively filling certain
points to make you think wrong things
I would say that Independent Media is
raw milk butter Washington Post is
canola oil that's the way for me to help
people understand this personally myself
but uh margarine yeah yeah exactly but
but you know Gene what do you see
happening because you know more and more
Independent Media is getting a bigger
voice we're becoming more prominent how
do you see this kind of media landscape
moving forward because it does seem like
the old guard the dinosaur media the
prostitutes the horse tree media they're
just going down in droves and I it's
it's you know I I hate to celebrate
something negative but it's good to see
a changing on the guard myself look it's
it's really good to see it changing the
guard the stuff that you guys are doing
the stuff that other folks are doing is
fantastic because you're covering issues
that people care about you're talking
about things in depth in a way that
people care about not in a way that some
person based in Washington DC is
deciding how to tell you about the
information you are engaging on it
you're having an in-depth discussion I
mean it's it's free it's open people
like to listen to it they're a part of
the conversation station but another
piece of this though with the with the
old Legacy Media that you know I don't I
don't hear a ton of folks talking about
is so much of the Legacy Media has been
centralized and nationalized right and
so every story is coming out of
Washington every story's coming out of
uh of D of DC of New York whatever local
news
truly local news we once had local
newspapers all across this country that
reported on things that affected things
in communities things that actually
affected folks everyday lives and those
have all gone by the wayside and I think
personally that's a huge tragedy because
folks don't even know what's going on in
their own neighborhoods their own towns
their own their own local cities but
yeah they can probably tell you what you
know Nancy Pelosi said
um you know or what Donald Trump said or
what anyone said because everything's
become so nationalized and if we can get
if we can support local Outlets again or
find a way to get the local news covered
and then with the independent Outlets
cover the actual issues I think would be
in a much better place as a society
I I think also another solution for Elon
Musk there instead of just having yellow
verified badges you should have glowing
verified badges for all
problem didn't see connected Muse
organizations that aren't really news
organizations they're just doing PR for
some of the richest people in this world
and the special interests who are really
in charge pulling the strings behind Joe
Biden well that's just my two cents and
and you know what he should do these
verification badges should not be
optional so like he's basically saying
if you want to get verified you gotta
get Twitter blue and if you're an
official Advertiser you get the the
business verification there should just
be Bots that are operated as sock
puppets by us intelligence agencies he
knows and he gives them all like a
glowing you know verification badge and
when you highlight it it says this
account is verified because it's run by
uh governmental intelligence operation
that would be fantastic yeah absolutely
make them glow let me let me let me tell
you why uh so we just we just talked
about how the Washington Post is laying
people off and I described the feeling
as pleasure derived from the suffering
of my enemies schadenfrotta let me
explain to you why from fortune.com
people who skipped their covid vaccine
are at higher risk of traffic accidents
according to a new study
really okay uh I'm ready to see every
every meteorologist just gutted at at
this point just just fire em all we need
to get some some billionaires like Elon
Elon you bought Twitter you can buy
these outlets for much cheaper buy them
just fire everybody just just just no
more I'm I can't I can't anymore with
this what does getting vaccinated have
to do with getting into a car accident
well my guess is that they did a study
uh or a group of studies and they found
that people that hadn't been vaccinated
had gotten into more car accidents in
the past and then now they're
extrapolating in some unfounded
conclusion that it means in the future
they're also going to be a risk of it
which is insane it's inaccurate that's
my guess I haven't read the article yet
but let's find it I forgot who said this
but someone responded to this story
saying that's because all the vaccinated
people are suffering heart attacks in
their homes and not driving their cars
that's one possibility who knows I'm not
a medical doctor so
but again this is desperate propaganda
just trying to Gaslight people to push a
big Pharma product that extensively is
being used as a form of compliance for
the general public I got it I gotta say
you know as I always do talk to your
doctor about what's right for you right
don't don't get advice from podcasts I
just gotta say however if you go to your
doctor and say Doc now I haven't gotten
the vaccine am I at risk for getting
into a car accident he's gonna be like
what according to fortunately
I got another idea this is a threat to
all the unvaccinated people saying hey
you're not vaccinated you're gonna get
in a car accident here and we're gonna
make sure you're gonna take this or else
how else how else could they get so
desperate how else this is ridiculous
Last Christmas I think Biden told people
you're in for a season of death of
severe death and illness and I remember
being on the show being like that's not
happening it's propaganda it's going to
be Biden in a car and he's gonna he's
gonna be like sitting like across the
street with this engine off and he sees
you leave your house
and then he speeds around Cuts you off
and then T-Bones you Dr Fountain
Fisher-Price car yeah
Biden gets out and goes
come on man get vaccinated I don't think
it would happen too late but it's
possible that a society would track
everyone that got vaccinated like the
CCP has been doing tracking people and
then start intentionally harming people
that haven't been vaccinated and then
blaming it on them not getting
vaccinated not I don't think there's any
evidence that that's happened but that
could be a move okay well to be fair
let's read what they're saying they say
if you passed on getting the covid
vaccine you might be a lot more likely
to get into a car crash or at least
those are the findings of a new study
published this month in the American
Journal of Medicine during the summer of
2021 Canadian researchers examined the
encrypted government held records of
more than 11 million adults 16 percent
of whom hadn't received the vaccine they
found that the unvaccinated people were
72 percent more likely to be involved in
a severe traffic crash in which at least
one person was transported to the
hospital than those who were vaccinated
that's similar to The increased risk of
car crashes for people who with sleep
apnea though only about half of the
people who abuse alcohol research is
fine
the excess risk of a car crash posed by
unvaccinated drivers exceeds the safety
gains from Modern automobile engineering
advances and also imposes risks on other
Road users the authors wrote
all right
I wouldn't be surprised if where we're
going with this is we're hereby
announcing that your driver's license
cannot be renewed unless you are up to
date on your vaccines I think they were
already doing that in some some places
like you need to prove a vaccination or
whatever but where that then brings us
is no one's allowed to drive anymore
self-driving cars only I think this
article is a self-owned they did say
that it might the headline says that it
is and then the first sentence is that
it might so they're contradicting
themselves this says they are at a
higher risk and then the first sentence
says they might be so that's a lie
they're lying in some way and then it's
exactly what I said earlier it was a
something in the past indicated that
more people that hadn't been vaccinated
got into 72 percent more car accidents
in a study that does not indicate that
in the future that will also happen that
is not an indication of that Ian stop
questioning the science how do you think
this is science hold on I can actually
break down for you why this is true it
has to do with risk I'm assuming there
are people that are more willing to take
more risk it's real simple people who
got vaccinated they were more likely to
stay home terrified of getting sick and
people who didn't were more likely to go
out and keep working true so what did
they find well gee look at all these yes
because people who go outside face
danger yeah I love it and now there's
going I'm telling you Christmas is
coming up and there's going to be
someone in your family who's like well
you should have went and gotten the
vaccine because now you're gonna get in
a car accident and you're gonna be like
Ma what are you talking about that makes
no sense well I was watching the MSNBC
and they said oh geez you gotta be like
oh yeah Fortune Magazine
what are you talking about News Guard
certified 100 out of 100. all right well
that's got to come down
you know I was uh I was thinking about
that Yuri besman up quote where he said
someone who's totally demoralized you
could you could tell them show them
proof that Black is Black is white and
white is white and they won't they
cannot be you know taken out of this
and I'm thinking just that that explains
it and that interviews from what 40
years ago yeah where he's talking about
demoralization it explains how you can
actually go to someone and say here is a
picture of the thing and they'll be like
nah uh okay well then what do you do man
if if there are people who just like eat
this stuff up and believe it and they
lack the ability to understand nuance
what what is the end result half the
planet implodes the other half just
rebuild if you do nothing but you can
give people morale boosts great
commanders do that great artists can do
that and that'll wake people up in their
own mind you know and then they'll start
to notice their surroundings you know
this is what I was talking about with
the Washington Post thing how when you
watch a show like this we try and break
down the story we try to make sense of
it and if you read the news they just
say this garbage
the headline should literally say
ridiculous study claims people who Skip
the code of vaccine at a higher risk for
traffic accidents ignores
ignores common sense and then it could
have said right away people who were
getting the vaccine were probably more
likely to stay home and people who
didn't were probably more likely to go
out and if you go outside you're more
likely to get in a car accident story's
over have a nice day or they could have
just said hey we're desperate we're
getting being uh we're being paid by big
Pharma to chill for this just please
take it uh Gene with this news story
make you take the vaccine
well someone who's been in a few car
accidents um you know no
um look I this is exactly you all of you
guys are correct you're making a really
good points which is there are special
influences who are funding a lot of
these studies and these polls and the
things that you see that are driving
news and there's a failure from the
Legacy Media and from Outlets that are
News Guard certified to actually report
things in a way that makes sense to
people I mean it it that was the most
nonsensical thing you could you could
ever imagine every American knows
correlation is not causation but here we
are and uh you know you see something
like that and it's it's it if that
doesn't strike that headline doesn't
strike you is absolute insanity and
divorced from reality then like you you
ought to go get your head examined you
ought to go get go talk to somebody
because there's something wrong you you
aren't able to understand things clearly
they're not examined it's probably a lot
of gut trauma yeah maybe but they're
just gonna what they're gonna do is
they're gonna try and find some want to
affirm them right and then they'll just
be like please tell me I'm right they'll
say you're right but I don't think those
people are happy I know that state of
mind when people are like please just
put me back in the Pod but it really
it's not like a blissful happiness State
those people they want more and when
they realize there's more when when you
control your own reality that I think
it's much more enjoyable for people and
they do seek that out when they when
they know it's available you know uh
considering I I'd be willing I'd be
willing to State I bet you'll see other
correlations in this way because and
this is just my speculation the people
who are scared enough who want like the
people who are not worried and didn't
get vaccinated probably went out and
went outside so I'm I I bet you could
find a correlation between people who
are vaccinated and the amount of vitamin
D in someone's system or people who are
vaccinated probably stayed inside and
it's not just because of fear it's
because people in New York more likely
to be vaccinated Than People in West
Virginia West Virginia in the middle of
nowhere and you're neighbors you know a
football field away so you're just like
I ain't gonna touch anything or anybody
what am I worried about you live in New
York you're in a cubicle smashed up next
to people and you can't go eat unless
you get proof of vaccination you're more
likely to be locked inside you're more
likely to get the vaccine I bet you'll I
bet you'll even find higher instances of
organic food consumption among people
who aren't vaccinated because they're
going to be conservative people out in
rural areas who are eating like farm
meat that's like grass-fed beef and
stuff like that yeah there's a lot of
different data out there and I think
there's also data that's not being
looked at and ignored and not calculated
that also should be I see Florida making
a big step in the right direction now
officially saying that they're going to
be launching investigations they're
going to be looking into the
correlations they're going to be looking
into some of the possible big problems
here uh and and again data could be
twisted and manipulated in many
different ways but there's a lot of
glaring data that does com complicates
the picture of what we're seeing here
especially when it comes to Sweden
especially when it comes to Haiti
especially when it comes to the
countries in Africa there's a a lot of
questions that should be asked here
there should be more data there should
be more investigations and the only
people doing them is is a state of the
United States it's only Florida doing
these investigations come on we could do
better the truth matters here at the end
of the day we should be investigating we
should be getting the data we're not
which is uh an absolute shame have you
been involved in any of these
investigations look I mean we have some
investigations about the communications
between the government and some of these
private entities that we've been
undertaking that we started when Jin
saki sat at the White House Podium last
summer and said hey we've been
collaborating with these tech companies
and we're flagging this information
disinformation but in terms of the the
the side effects of some of these things
and in some of the you know being at
increased risk of myocarditis and all of
these other issues are things that like
it's great that the State of Florida is
doing that that is the kind of thing
that any objective good government would
do is you search out the truth
you're not afraid of the truth you ask
the questions and you follow the line to
to its logical conclusion well so so
tell us what's going on with uh we've
got all these stories about big tech
colluding for political reasons you know
uh DNC Democratic officials reach out to
Twitter things like that but there were
there was also uh information pertaining
to researching covid we recently saw a
tweet I think the Hodge twins tweeted at
Elon and said did like let me guess you
saw a tweet between the government and
Twitter discussing censoring covet
information and then he posted a trophy
so what's what's going on with that you
guys had something recently right yeah
so we've put out a number of things a
number of uh you know
press releases that turn into kind of
long articles folks can read through and
see themselves where we pull the
documents we get screen screenshots
screen grabs of the text I love folks
you know hey here it is here's so-and-so
government official talking to so-and-so
with this platform we've put a few
different things out and we're putting
these things out and we're going to
continue to do it on a rolling basis
because it's the result of a lawsuit
that we had to file against the
government to get this data out and so
every time we get a batch of data we're
trying to pull out there get the
Highlights you know bring it to folks
and let the American people see what was
going on behind the scenes so the latest
thing that we have here which is similar
to something else we had was this back
Channel reporting uh reporting Channel
at Twitter where government officials
were able to log in and flag information
that they deemed as misinformation for
Twitter employees to purge from their
system the same thing existed at
Facebook from the records that we've
been able to see we have an example of a
woman who worked for the CDC who used
her personal Twitter account Twitter
gave her her through her personal
Twitter account the ability to log in in
flag misinformation and disinformation
and they actually encouraged her to do
it because they said it was the best way
to get something like that reviewed
which the the that in that case being
the posts and the information they
determined were misinformation so look
it's it's it's that's just the top of
the layer of the onion though there's so
many layers beneath it between
intergovernmental uh organizations
non-governmental organizations
non-profit set up there's a whole kind
of regime that was built up around this
misinformation disinformation uh you
know thing and they're using the
government they're using the powers of
government and they were using the
powers of one of the biggest social
media platforms out there to objectively
Define for the American people what was
true and what was false when people from
the government would flag something as
this or misinformation is there are
there instances where the people at
Twitter would say no it's not and just
ignore them so we haven't seen yet and
that's part of the problem is that
because these portals exist
some of these things are never going to
be disclosed from government records
this always great for the government
actors to be able to do this because it
it obscures reality it is there's no
record to go back and check on if you
send an email or do something from a
government computer there's going to be
a record that you're going to be able to
go back and check but because they were
using a private platforms software
there's not going to be a way for us to
be able to determine how much they
actually flagged for these companies and
what the companies actually did with it
what we do have examples of are examples
of the private companies pulling down
content so we don't have examples yet
that I that I'm aware of that we've seen
where they've ever said oh hey no sorry
you know that we disagree with you on
this but we have seen examples of where
the private platforms have said yes
thank you we're happy to do that can you
can we do more for you what else can we
do for you government
um it just in a really shocking way that
I think most Americans would find truly
offensive yeah I think that there's uh
probably tendency for governments across
the history of time to hire external
organizations to do dirty work like
mercenaries right um things like that I
just don't like seeing it turned on the
people themselves by having government
officials use their private accounts to
have undocumented Communications with my
social media Network that I've been
using right right no I mean it's it's
exactly right it's like one of the
oldest plays in the book and the thing
about it is that of course the
government can't do that legally they
can't violate the First Amendment
through Contracting the work out to a
private company to do for them that's
that's against the law you can't do that
so there's there's gonna have to be some
real accountability here luckily there
are some things moving that hopefully
will bring that one of which being a
lawsuit that was filed by the states of
Missouri and Louisiana where they're
deposing folks right now I'm sure some
of your some of your viewers and
listeners have have been tracking that
that uh you know Elvis Chan was part of
this uh lawsuit he was just recently
deposed I think Jen saki's related to be
deposed at some point actually getting
people in chairs asking them the
questions about what happened what was
going on here is going to be critical
and I you know we'll see what happens as
the result of the lawsuit but it should
shock the conscience of everyone
regardless of your perspective it should
shock your conscience that the
government would be able to do this
especially when you look at what they
were saying was false
in a lot of cases later became actually
hey actually that wasn't false and so
this meaning of Truth this divorced
reality of what's true and what's false
you know is an evolving thing for the
for the government and for the for the
left collectively and it leads to a
place where you can be censored as long
as you're just not agreeing with what
the what the current woke thought is and
in in with with covid stuff it was all
over the place we all lived it we lived
it for about two years think about how
crazy the the legal system is in terms
of perjury like what we've learned the
true extent of it
I I think perjury is a non-existent
thing at this point because what we have
here is uh you know Mr Dorsey do you
Shadow ban we don't you don't no you you
don't remove people that their knowledge
we visibility filter
so what
did you did what did you say the other
day I don't know if it was you I was
like did you stab this man no I placed a
knife inside his body that was Luke he
put his chest all around my blade
do you have a door to your building no
we have a portal and and there is a a
vertical uh slat of wood with a a grip
on it so semantic dodging semantics is a
form of perjury I think we can be clear
about that Anthony fauci said they
didn't do gain a function James Clapper
said he had no winning knowledge of
spying on the American people even
though prism showed that they did yep
right yeah he's like we we didn't do
gain of function research what we did
was manipulate viruses to make them more
deadly and dangerous it's like and
transmissible to human beings and then
ramp that's what the same exact one that
just naturally got out there because
someone ate a bat in China Rand Paul
holds up the paper and he's like uh it
says right here that you were doing gain
of function and he goes no it says on
the paper no
and there's and what and where's fauci
he's on MSNBC and they're like I can't
believe Elon would say prosecute fauci I
can he lied to Congress man look when it
comes to this stuff they all just lie we
watch them lie we know they're lying
they know we know they're lying we know
they know we know they're lying and
we're all just staring at each other
like nothing will change people get
charged people get charged for lying
under oath people get charged for lying
to Congress look what happened to Oliver
Stone he went down he went to jail
because he lied to Congressman well I
thought you could do it Brennan could do
it come on let's let's play fair here
let's actually hold people accountable
to what they said to how they lied to
the American people and how they screwed
them over oh you're talking about Roger
Stone not Oliver sorry I apologize
we should have yeah I interviewed him
before too uh I don't always agree with
him fascinating guy he interviewed Putin
has a lot of context uh specifically
about Russia and Venezuela that I uh
definitely see differently than him but
it would be great to have him on the
show and have that conversation the
reason my apologies from my mistake yeah
Oliver uh the reason we have a
government for the People by the people
is because if the people that we put in
charge start lying to us we're supposed
to remove them from office and then
maintain balance and honesty and
integrity in our system maybe the whole
system has always been predicated on
lies maybe yes and you we just want to
close our eyes and believe that they're
doing the right thing when we put them
in power to lie for us you know I I
probably I imagine it like this
pre-radio you had
um people who hung out in their own
communities talk to each other and trust
each other and they did not trust for
the most part centralized media you know
distribution the printing press
relatively new in the you know uh
new-ish in the in the in the you know
before the American Revolution then they
started using this to put out propaganda
being like we should be independent it
affects people they hear it but for the
most part your life is still very much
oh I'm gonna do it the Patriot with Mel
Gibson what a good movie
they're they're you know in their house
and then a postal writer comes they're
like it's a there's a letter whoa like
words come from town
when gathers around to read
it's like I get 50
being on Twitter but so back then you
believed what you believed or you didn't
you saw what you saw or you didn't and
there was no centralized communication
grid then you got radio and TV and all
of a sudden well actually even before
that you had the massive National
Distribution of newspapers which started
you know started getting really really
big in the late 1800s and then the turn
of the century everyone's now believing
the papers then everyone's believing the
radio then everyone's believing the TV
and it's all centralized and it was
probably all lies
but we believed it because that's what
we were told the radio the internet
comes out and we once again are
decentralizing our flaw of information
and we're getting into this
revolutionary period I guess
the uh the radio changed it all it did
because I remember Orson Welles did that
War of the Worlds radio show and people
actually believed it was real that
aliens were attacking it was so
believable on the radio is this new
technology they went outside I heard
that people killed themselves because
they thought we were under attack by
aliens I don't know if that's confirmed
but then the then video comes or film uh
and film allows the centralization of
power for Hitler like Hitler is the
result of that centralization of Power
with that mass media mind control
technique now we have the internet and
it's like a we have both centralization
and decentralization kind of
at odds or or coming at each other and
trying to figure out the best way to
have like localized decentralized
centralized systems well this is why you
end up with uh who is that woman who did
the musical number about disinformation
you know what I'm talking about
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah this is why you
get these people right because they know
they're lying it's why you get people
like Taylor Lorenz and Ben Collins they
know they're lying of course they do
they they know they're making up things
but they're doing it in service of the
authoritarian narrative machine
these are people who long for a world
where like like uh was it Mika
Brzezinski said is that his her name
Amiga Micah where she said it's our job
to tell people what to think she was
like Trump thinks he can tell people to
think that's our job and then Snopes
immediately comes out to debunk the
claims she said it when she literally
said but that's not what you mean what
they want is they want to go on TV and
say the sky is red and then have
everyone be like whatever you say boss
and the problem is now with the internet
we all start posting online well the sky
can be read sometimes depending on the
sunset but for the most part it's blue
so they're actually just manipulating
you and then someone says you're so dumb
this guy is red it's seven it's 7 pm at
Sunset it's like dude I know and then
you argue but that argument is part of
the Nuance in the conversation they
don't want they want to say no it's red
stop talking about it anybody who thinks
the sky is blue report to your education
center
you want to know that people are not we
are not built to fall in line I mean
there's part of us that work we're
definitely community based organisms but
we're not like you can't force people
into slavery it doesn't make sense it
never has worked in the history of
humanity we've always come away from it
for a while well you know if you look at
human history there's a lot of slavery
there's a lot of War there's a lot of
Destruction there's people like Genghis
Khan there's individuals that try to
conquer the world and control all of it
and try to uh have all of it for
themselves so so that's common that
always has happened and for us to think
that this has gotten this has somehow
left the the The Human Experience it's I
think it's foolish and I think there's a
lot of other smarter people out there
that are still going for these same
goals we just don't know about them we
don't hear about them and they're going
for these larger uh Personal Achievement
achievements for themselves in secret
it's like the the spirit of Moses is to
free the slaves and like the spirit of
the United States the Statue of Liberty
is a freed slave and they but the
businessmen that got the Statue of
Liberty put up there didn't want to show
the chains on her wrists they were like
no we can't remind people that we're
free we want them to forget they're on
our feet right yeah so they put the
chains down at her feet where you can't
see it because you're looking up at it
but if you look at it from above you see
broken chains she's a freed slave the
French understand Liberty as the United
as the Americans do but the businessmen
don't they don't like that they want us
to lull back into just worshiping some
erudite they want us to think oh she's
studied so she's great no she's great
because she was a freed slave she will
never go back is it isn't it like
everybody's related to Genghis Khan or
something or like
of the world I think is because he was
banging a lot of chicks you know yeah he
was going around taking Villages and
taking the women I think it's like
one-third in Asia everybody I think like
it's like history we go into slavery and
then we come out of it and then we go
back into it we come out of it and we're
trying to remind ourselves not to go
back into it yeah that's the story of
America of the United States do not fall
back into monarchy do not fall back
under the subservience of one man in a
corporation don't do it it's it's not
you know I don't know if monarchy is the
right word but we've fallen into
something new we haven't yet defined
right so we have these words to describe
things that we probably didn't describe
when they were initially conceived of
when feudalism first came into existence
there wasn't some guy who looked around
and went this is feudalism you know it
was it was like the way things were and
then eventually we start to Define these
things so whatever and we're in now it
is not democracy it is not
constitutional republicanism something
totally different I mean it could just
be uh
a quasi you know revolutionary state
where you've got as as we've talked
about in the show a multicultural
democracy trying to exist within a
constitutional republic and they're both
at odds with each other and so they're
conflicted but it's certainly not one of
the other and you can't describe it that
way maybe we'll uh corporate
technagopoly yeah we'll we'll come up
with some new word for it like communism
was a word that was coined fascism was a
word that was a coin can we make up a
new word for whatever it is we're going
through yeah
is another one but but uh throughout my
understanding of of you know history I
think America is a rare experiment in
Freedom I mean and it's still one of the
few countries in the world where you
have the first and second amendment you
don't have that in a lot of places
around the world and there are a lot of
people that hate that because if people
could say what they want and be able to
defend themselves by being able to say
what they want that is rare from my
understanding unless someone else could
prove me wrong and I think the these are
important god-given rights that need to
be protected at all costs but let's be
fair and honest with ourselves this
latest technocratic advancement and take
over of our society is challenging that
especially with Joe Biden uh coming out
saying that he's going to be making more
actions against the Second Amendment
especially with tech platforms Tick Tock
Facebook Google alphabet all these
companies essentially doing a form of
Mind Control there's a lot of uh you
know freedoms that are threatened more
than ever I don't know that's my
perspective what do you think look I I
think y'all are on to something here
um and I think that there's also a
generational aspect to consider for this
so you know I I don't know how old you
guys are or young you are or whatever
but I can recall at least when I was
growing up a sense especially among
young men of rebellion it's in the heart
of every young men for generations of to
kind of like say to authority to the
authority figures no I'm not going to do
what you tell me I mean I think there
was even a lie in a Rage Against the
Machine song that had something to say
about that yeah but now it's shut up you
better do what they tell you exactly
that's exactly what it is and we have we
have a generation that is complacent now
and I don't know if it's the result of
the influence of of the social media at
least as it existed until now
um with all of these other things but
we've gotten to a place where young
people are afraid to question authority
they're afraid to question people as to
hey why am I being told that I have to
think this way why am I being told that
I have to get this you know why do I
have to behave this way or I'm
ostracized that no one ever asked those
open open questions now and I think
that's it's a real problem I was reading
this uh blog about comics and
superheroes a while ago and it talked
about how in the in the in the ancient
stories were of defying The Authority
like stealing fire from Mount Olympus or
whatever or Hercules fighting the I
don't know what the exact story is it's
been a while since I read it but it was
talking about how the heroes used to
challenge those in control the gods and
things like that and superheroes today
are very much completely in line with
the authority
so Superman for instance he doesn't
break the law he's got to fight for the
government now there's been Nuance
introduced in the comics over time but
there was this period where very much
everything was whatever the government
says goes and so uh we went to
Fredericksburg this past weekend we were
hanging out with Matt Strickland over at
gormeltz shout out Matt amazing food by
the way and this is the this is the
business where this all comes together
in a perfect story I gotta be honest
this is where the the Government tried
shutting down his business because of
Kobe he said screw off we're not
shutting down two years later they take
his alcohol his liquor license from him
and and and he's like what's going on we
got young in but this is a guy who's
defying the machine standing up for what
he believes and standing up for his
community while we're down there
we we you know we eat food we hang out
them we're like this is a whole lot of
fun and then we'd say we're gonna we're
gonna go check out the city we go to
this antique store
and I see an old comic from the from
World War II it was um I think it was
DC's the Unknown Soldier
and the cover shows a bunch of children
standing in front of Nazis and the
unknown soldiers on top of a tank
pointing at them saying it doesn't
matter that they're hiding behind
children man we have to do it or
something like that and I was like I
called Luke I was like dude you got to
look at this
World War II comic books of the of the
good guy saying it doesn't matter that
there are children in front of front of
these soldiers
and the tank is pointed at them the
artillery and I'm like I get it like the
U.S was right under no circumstances do
you stop fighting even if it means
running kids over or shooting at them or
whatever and that's to the extent that
our heroes began to support the machine
even when they were doing things that
were atrocious or it's just one example
that I saw granted these days there's
been a bit more Nuance in superhero
comics you now have like the uh the
Marvel Civil War series now I don't mean
the movie the superhero registration act
comic Arc was was great where you know
you had like Tony Stark as a corporatist
and he's like well the government wants
us to register so we should hit Captain
America all of a sudden defying the
government being like I'm not for this
that's not the American way that Nuance
was really really great but but I do
find it interesting that when when you
ultimately get these people like was his
name Phoenix Jones
he was that guy who was a vigilante and
what was it Seattle yeah you guys know I
think so he ends up during the like
these antifa riots helping the cops and
they were like you're a bad guy you're
helping the cops and he's like what do
you mean that's what superheroes do
so it's interesting to see that we're at
this point you know I suppose
they're supposed to I mean Law and Order
for the for MO is supposed to be good I
think that I tend towards neutrality
when it comes to law and Chaos I find
myself like if if it's good chaos that's
better than evil law
um but I tend towards law over chaos
because I find that law allows the
system to balance out a little bit
better than chaos but can chaos be good
or bad yeah chaos can be good you can
have like Robin Hood for instance would
steal from like wealthy landowners and
then give to the poor people they said
that was a good act but it's very
chaotic to steal yeah I I see what
you're saying Robin Hood was not acting
in a predictable Manner and so the
machine was disrupted by his actions but
he was doing things to stop the villains
to help the poor exactly and the
villains were the law which was King
John the drunken brother of King Richard
who I I think that the story that's a
story in reality they weren't living in
the same time and King John was a he was
a lion wasn't he no his brother was The
Lion Heart King Richard but uh King
Richard John was just uh it was a fox
yeah oh yeah you're right yeah Disney
Disney is history I personally think uh
the boys on Amazon Prime definitely has
a better representation of what's
Happening behind the scenes especially
with PR and large government and even
though it's filled with a lot of woke
propaganda I I do see that more of a
reality than anything else from my
perspective I don't know what's your
favorite dystopian uh nightmare that's
coming true to life the one we're in
yeah I mean it's it's it's hard
it's hard to describe I mean imagine
describing reality today to yourself 10
years ago I love it right I mean it's
it's it's one of these things you sit
there and you think okay so take
yourself go back to wherever you were 10
years ago and tell yourself hey in 10
years from now if you do so much as say
Hey you know like uh 10 years in in 10
years people are going to be having drag
queens dancing in front of children and
you're gonna be called a bigot if you
ask a question about it I think most
folks around here
um would say well you're you're totally
crazy you've lost your mind and so in a
lot of ways what we have seen rapidly
over the last decade has descended us
into kind of our own
dystopian world where it's not
recognizable by prior generations of
Americans who who have this unifying
kind of common common experience common
identity common values that unify them
as Americans people from all over the
world people from all the world United
behind this idea that we have this
institutional Republic we have the
societal values that we're going to
uphold and yet you know you go to where
we are today and it's because of the
increase of the influence of this woke
mob that you get you get things where
people are denying just fundamental
truth things that everyone understood to
be real for Millennia
um but it's it is you were called a
bigot if you are dare to speak out
whatever the the current thinking is and
of course the the the ancillary part of
that is that that is an ever-shifting
and evolving Target for the woke mob
It's never enough you know they once
they get to something that they want
they have to increase their power and so
their their targets continue to move and
you're never going to be woke enough for
them it's just a matter of who gets
canceled in time and who is able to keep
being woke and going along with the
crowd until they're called out yeah like
no true Scotsman policy right there is
there any like court case you're working
on right now what would you say is the
most important legal case you guys are
working on right now so the there's a
number of them that are that are I think
particularly important particularly
impactful for the average American which
is something that I try to think about
as we look at the cases that we bring
the things that we're going to do hey
what's going to have the most positive
benefit for the American people and so
you know we we have an active case
representing a federal uh employee who
was challenging the covid vaccine
mandate you know again one of these
attempts to to force employees to to get
the jab even if they didn't want to or
even if they had coveted before we're
active in that case we were part of the
Coalition of of organizations that
brought down the the OSHA mandate we've
we've been successful in stopping a
number of
programs that discriminate against
American citizens on the basis of their
race right and so it's it's again for us
it's we look at this and we say all
racism is wrong it's always been wrong
it still is wrong it always will be
wrong no one should be treated
differently because of the color of
their skin but you have government
programs out there that are coming out
like this Farm loan forgiveness program
that came out this restaurant
revitalization program that came out uh
or you know even faculty hiring at
different major universities that say
hey you're only eligible for this if
you come from this background if you
have this color of skin that's totally
unacceptable skin color should never be
the basis for any kind of governmental
action or any kind of private
Corporation action it should never it
shouldn't matter if you want to look at
other things like socioeconomic
conditions you know maybe it's a you
know you want to provide help to the
poor people in Appalachia the same way
you would help someone in the inner city
great fantastic but you can't do it on
the basis of race so we've successfully
stopped a number of these programs that
the administration and the Congress have
rolled out and we're proud to have done
so because again you know all racism is
wrong it always will be wrong yeah I
remember uh not so long ago talking to
my members on my member area this is
about you know almost now two years from
now telling people hey if your boss
comes to you and tries to force you to
take a medical procedure or threaten to
fire you whatever you do don't quit let
them fire you document everything I got
a lot of people contacting me saying
thank you for telling me this because
now they have legal cases that are going
to court and they're getting a lot of
settlements because it you know
discriminating against someone extorting
someone manipulating someone to do
something when there's no liability from
the producers of this something
clearly brings up a lot of very
important issues that a lot of people
have forgotten and when we had these
conversations about people getting
discriminated against it being fired no
one brought up like hey we have a legal
set of rules and laws here that should
be followed now they are so what was
your experience uh you know in that
particular realm and how do you see it
moving forward from here because there's
still a lot of discrimination there's
still a lot of craziness can you fight
it all can we get justice for all this
yeah look I mean it's going to depend on
the nature of the employer of course the
government employers are the easiest
ones to to Target right because the
government has a set of rules and
restrictions that that set it to a
standard that's much you know different
than what a private employer could do
because a private employer should have
the right to be able to do you know more
or less with certain exceptions what
they want to do with their own Workforce
you know subject to applicable laws that
said uh I I think that I am optimistic
about what the future holds I think that
the for the federal civilian Workforce I
think there's going to be a real good
win here soon uh hopefully out of out of
the fifth circuit uh you know I don't
know about our own case how that's going
to do with the DC circuit but hopefully
there's something there that freeze
literally I mean look I mean some people
might say well it's a bunch of
government bureaucrats these are real
people millions of federal workers who
were subjected to either hey you take
the jab or you know you'd lose your job
and that's not a place that you want to
be in some of the private employers I
know there's been some good wins from
some different folks across the country
um I think there's a a group of folks
who worked in a hospital system up north
as I recall who recently prevailed and
they got some back pay and compensatory
damages which is great
um but it's look it's challenging
because you know whether it's whether
it's in the nature of the covid uh you
know vaccine or whether it's in the
nature of discrimination claims or
anything else there's a lot of just
cross currents that discard people from
being free to exercise you know their
god-given Liberties and rights as
Americans and you know another another
example of kind of the woke mob going
after something is this case we recently
won in Texas
um where we represented a class of
doctors in America who are about to be
subject to a Biden Administration edict
that said if you discriminate against
someone on the basis of their gender
identity
then you're discriminating against them
on the basis of their sex and therefore
you're going to be subject to claims of
discrimination so if you're a doctor who
has a patient who comes to you and says
who is a biological male
but believes they're a woman and says
hey I I need to be treated um for you
know whatever you name you name the
condition and the doctor says no well
you're a biological male I can't do that
for you they would be subject to just
they would be subject to government
investigations for discrimination and if
found to have uh discriminated against
someone on that basis they lose access
to Federal funding which is disastrous
for any kind of Doctor Who's providing
any kind of care yeah and so we we want
a case
um on behalf of a class of all doctors
in America where we've said hey that
interpretation is unlawful and so these
doctors are now free to go about
exercising their independent medical
adjustment uh medical judgment and
provide the care that they think is
right but there's all kinds of cross
currents here that are going on in in
American society or the woke left is
just ever advancing and we need more
folks on the right or in the center for
that matter pushing back and fighting
back and saying no like this is not
going to happen we'll we'll we will not
stand for this and also why it's not
going to happen because if you treat
someone with this a biological male but
you treat them as if they're a
biological female because their gender
they might die so we cannot go that
route we can't
right that's the crazy thing to me about
a lot of these stories is uh
you know there was a there's a viral
clip going around where this this uh
woman she's she runs a non-profit she
says parents have no right to know what
their kids are are experiencing or going
through or whatever and she said because
you know we prevent suicide we save
lives it's exactly what Jack Dorsey said
to me about their misgendering policy
and I was like on the on the face that
made no sense I was like so what about
body dysmorphic disorder or whatever
they're like what is that like like
somebody who feels their hand shouldn't
be on their body and they want to cut it
off are you gonna if someone goes on
Twitter and says I'm gonna go get my
hand removed and we say please don't
stop that's wrong are we gonna get
banned for that and they're like uh I
don't know so I'm wondering where that
comes from because it like the the point
is brought up all the time anorexia when
someone comes out and says I'm fat you
go no you're not
that's what you're supposed to say but
if someone comes out and says I'm in the
wrong body we're supposed to say okay
but only for that one issue like if
someone says they're an owl can you know
like other kids stuff and they say like
deep down I am a wolf you know like
because South Park did an episode about
it where it was Kyle's dad becomes a
dolphin yeah like at what point do you
say you you've got to be who you are you
know yeah yeah look I mean I
again for Millennia Millennia people
understood man woman okay great fine you
know but it's only been recently and
again it's really within the last 10
years or so that we have this increase
of hey not only uh uh not only are there
67 or 72 genders or whatever the case
may be these days Infinity it's whatever
whatever limit you can't have it's also
you're a bigot you're a bigot if you
reject uh their their invented identity
it's it's it's imposing on other people
in a way that we've never seen in our
you know Society I think but before uh
yeah I mean insane you know like I I
never really cared about if somebody
uses atypical pronouns in the sense that
like you know uh always using Blair
white is the example but Blair I just
say she I mean whatever I don't know
it's easy make sense uh Ben Shapiro
explained it as if if I'm going out and
I'm like hey go sit by my friend I'm
gonna grab some food where over there
that's her you know he's not going to
say that's him because it'll be
confusing and people would be like huh
because they see someone who clearly
looks like a female
but then you get into the Neo pronoun
stuff and now you've got these these
people saying like you should call
someone zorp and I'm like okay I look
man I can't remember that I'm not trying
to be a dick but I'm not saying it okay
because I don't know what you're talking
about and I can't be like
you know for all these people I just
can't do it yeah he and she and they I
get and then they're like but what about
if you accidentally call a woman a man
it's like then I'd apologize and then
use the correct pronouns like if if
there's a Burly woman and I say Excuse
me sir and they go I'm a woman I'm like
oh I'm sorry about that ma'am it's that
simple like we're not trying to be but
you can't then say but if someone wants
to go by zaires you know or or there's
like hydrogender so you know you call
them like flube or something yeah it's
like dude I don't know that I'm not
gonna remember it you're the only person
in the world who goes by that right like
the the argument they make is but if
someone's name is John would you not
call them John and I'm like I call them
by their name but I can't remember a
name and a pronoun for every single
person so it's just not gonna happen
yeah
think as like pronouns or just it's not
a one-to-one comparison but like gender
as opposed to sex gender could be
treated like a Cosmetic Skin in a video
game like it's like it it doesn't affect
the gameplay it's just how you what the
character resembles and that's kind of
what you but the thing is gender is a
psychological thing too so it does alter
the way you perceive reality I think is
part of why your gender is the way you
perceive it so it's not quite cosmetic
but legally it should be treated
cosmetically so this is the problem with
also some people saying well I get to
change my gender whenever I want how I
want when the government steps in like
in the United Kingdom and says oh if you
misgender someone you're going to jail
it happened in the United Kingdom I
interviewed someone randomly as I was
walking around in the United Kingdom I
was doing interviews about the first
amendment in the United Kingdom and I
ran into a guy who was arrested and had
to go to court because he called someone
a bloke let's let me let me pull this
story up and we'll keep talking about it
not on purpose by accident let me grab
this one from Fox News Norwegian
filmmaker faces up to three years in
prison for saying men cannot be lesbians
I can't pronounce this but uh chanye uh
how would you Chinese how do you
pronounce this again gevian is a lesbian
filmmaker who intentionally made the
comment to criticize Norway's hate
speech laws
so uh three years in prison uh Luke you
want to just rehash that like retell
that story for people who might just be
joining you you interviewed somebody who
was it was a very random thing I was
just walking around doing interviews on
the street met up a random guy and I was
like hey what do you think about the
First Amendment he and the guy was like
I wish I had it here I had to go to jail
I had to go to court I I was ostracized
for my community I was facing some
serious pressure from the government
because I accidentally called someone a
bloke in passing and then they called
the cops in them the cop showed up and
arrested a person uh for doing this he
was very severely negatively affected in
his career and faced a huge backlash for
an accident because he literally thought
that person was a bloke it wasn't a
bloke it was it was it was I I don't
know two famous stories zubi getting
suspended on Twitter for saying okay
dude and count dankula getting arrested
for posting a meme with his dog by you
know making his girlfriend's dog do the
the Nazis I call people dude in man like
woman man man and woman with a man in
the word I'm like hey guys what's up
everybody what's up dude homie hello and
I and it's not because of their sex I
don't care that's not why I'm casual
Survivor did a very cringe moment uh I
think it was either last season or the
season before that he was like I
wouldn't have a conversation with you
guys is it okay if I say guys I know for
the hot for so many years I said guys
but now I don't think it's okay are you
guys okay with me saying guys and then
and then and then the whole people were
like uh yeah he said are you guys okay
with me so I don't think he said it
exactly are you people okay if I say
guys what do you mean by he's very
careful he was very careful with how he
said it exactly right and then like
three days passed and then one of the
one of the uh contestants like you know
what Mike I I think you should stop
saying guys he's like okay you got it I
respect you all I'm like I was like why
is this on television like they just
ruined Survivor I used to love songs man
but they just ruined it you know what we
should do we gotta to do two things with
cast cats we got to do a skit where Ian
goes back in time to warn his younger
self about what's happening in the
future but Ian's younger self who's like
a crazy drugged out hippie is like dude
you must be on drugs yeah I'll be like
graphene and you got to talk about
graphene I'll be like this guy's insane
he talks about rapping all the time I
want nothing to do with him and then uh
the other one is take a bunch of woke
people and just you know as a sketch
drop them in the middle of the woods and
then ask them if the Bears care about
their pronouns
I mean like that my point with that is
all of these weird things they're
demanding are completely meaningless
like if we go to war with China do you
think like these soldiers that bunch of
U-boats or whatever like they start
coming up on the shores of California or
they they go into Alaska more likely if
there's going to be an invasion start
stealing stuff and there's gonna be an
American do you think they're gonna stop
and be like before we capture you what's
your pronoun
they're gonna be like get in the box and
your words are meaningless they don't
care about your problems especially if
like we start looking for water someone
tweeted that out what if all these this
drama that we're going through like what
if we run out of water for a day what
are we going to be talking about then
what if it's two days that we don't have
water what are we gonna be what's gonna
be the conversation on Twitter if we
don't have fresh water as a species
after two days no one's well all that's
going to be is where's the water well
that's cities though right rural fault
got water hopefully like for one there's
a river right here lots of water and
then we have wells and natural aquifers
and things like that so we're not
running out of water yeah God forbid any
kind of you know Celestial demonization
you know there's always meteoroids
technically a meteor is something that's
already entered the atmosphere the
meteoroid is the one that's still out
there so if you're in New York
and the flow of water stops man it's
going to get yeah no one cares what
gender you are if you're thirsty no one
cares it's all about survival
or hungry you know hunger too when when
when when there's no food left so uh how
long does food last on average like the
like three months or something like that
before all the food's basically gone
it's a refrigerated
just like in general there's there's
stuff that lasts longer but it gets
eaten and there's stuff that doesn't
last as long it's eaten and so I think
within like a few months if probably
faster than that if the supply the
supply line to New York cut off
how long do they have in terms of the
food supply in in the city like I'm
talking about at pantries at grocery
stores are they going to be eating
themselves
well what I'm saying is I think it might
even be a week all the perishable stuff
is spoiled all the fruits and vegetables
are spoiled within a week or two canned
goods are eaten up right after that so
in a couple weeks there's no food left
there's no water
the people who are stuck there what are
they gonna do yo it's going to be like
roving bands of cannibals yeah I'm not
even kidding there's people are going to
say I would rather not die and then
you're going to go outside and there's
gonna be a group and they're gonna knock
you and they're gonna they're gonna bash
you over the head and they're gonna drag
your body and that's their dinner yeah
long Pig and then they're not going to
ask you before we devour you what you
pronounce there could be in a chaotic
situation people will use gender to try
and divide people for control and power
I would imagine but if it's super
desperate we're like we're dying of
dehydration I don't think that anyone's
going to be thinking about that stuff
yeah yeah I mean that's literally what
it is like when you mentioned power it's
just power it's being able to tell
somebody else to do something for you
it's what Jordan Peterson's been saying
since like he came out this is the whole
thing it's always been about power it's
never been about anything else but Power
this is a complicize it communist
tactics man you find a victim class or
you create one and then you instill
communism thoughts the state will save
you the group can help you can take care
of you just do what we say just fall in
line with our orders and edicts right
exactly that's the bad guy yeah and
that's the reason you're suffering right
now oh man it's well in the in the other
thing about this the other Dynamic we've
been talking adults right but the number
of areas across the country that in my
organization America First legal we're
seeing is where the children
are being subjected to all kinds of just
crazy thoughts and I radical gender
ideology and it's being hidden from the
parents now look I mean there's one
thing if you're an adult and you want to
you know believe what you want to
believe but for a child for a elementary
school kid a middle school kid even a
high schooler like ultimately until
you're an emancipated adult your parents
have the right the fundamental right to
to bring up that child in the way that
they see fit and we have school
districts all across the country helping
transition their kid because they've
gotten some social club or whatever and
not telling the parents about it I mean
this this woke mob is really not
stopping anywhere and they're violating
the most fundamental relationships you
could ever imagine between a parent and
a child
and doing it under the guise of
protecting the child well the parents
might not be accepting of their new
identity so we have to hide it from them
it's a culture Revolution it's insane
it's crazy sever so you know we've
mentioned this before Prager is uh Cut
Flower politics I think it's called that
you can cut the flour from its you know
roots or whatever and it's beautiful and
you can show it to everybody but then it
dies right that that started happening
unintentionally I think but now what
we're seeing is the weaponization of
this
the opposite of honor thy father and thy
mother they're going to Schools they're
saying don't tell your parents and now
you've even got the White House
defending this Behavior saying parents
have no rights right so what's the story
with the White House getting involved
with this well this is just I mean you
know we'll get into that more in depth
for the members only I guess but this is
basically Biden saying that what's going
on with these schools is a good thing
it's the Democratic party saying don't
say gay like Florida comes out and says
parents have a right to know what's
going on with their kids and they go you
hate gay people yeah you know the Media
Matters put out this hit piece where
they're like
anti-lgbtq slur groomer and I'm like all
of my posts have been about how groomers
are not lgbtq why are you constantly
claiming that all LGBT people in you in
their view are pedophiles it's the
weirdest thing yeah it's it's medium
matters and love this organizations
trying to conflate these things it's at
the same time them trying to make sure
that kids are separated away from the
roots right you want they want they want
to create a revolution missionaries this
is why I just can't understand why I
hear these conservatives be like my kids
going to college
I'm like you know what dude I'm I'm not
even bothering with that one yeah you
know what happens to your kids in
college and they and they say things
like well there's good colleges though
there's good colleges I was like oh yeah
sure like in West Virginia where the
grade schools have genderqueer yeah
where in West Virginia the school board
is woke and I'm I'm not even kidding I'm
hearing these stories out of West
Virginia and I'm like you wouldn't think
that would be happening here it's
happening everywhere so these people are
like well you know I'm going to a good
college it's religious conservative yeah
DePaul wouldn't let Ben Shapiro on the
property so like you know what man
homeschool your kids have your kids
learn real skills self they can
self-teach a lot on the online I get it
you want to be a doctor or a lawyer you
need to sort of you need the official
legal certification yeah but that should
change too in my opinion I don't think
you need to go to school for 12 years
and 100 300 000 in debt to learn how to
do something that you could learn how to
do at your own pace like why do they
need to watch you and make sure that you
paid and became part of the system and
we're in Doc like if you can save
someone's life and understand and can
take the tests of medicine and can do
the surgeries why would why do you have
to go like I'm talking about reality
like we need doctors so
let's evolve that system I feel like
it's all just falling apart anyway
yeah but but this I don't think it's bad
news you know a lot of people think that
bringing up these things like collapses
pessimism it's realism but it's also an
opportunity right it means that there's
an opportunity as the the woke lunatics
burn down their cities and destroy
everything you have an opportunity in
your rural area to succeed to grow your
business and be self-sufficient stop
relying on the cities for for Revenue
make a new company start a new business
and a lot of people it's not easy to do
yeah figure it out yeah I mean literally
if you got a tree on your property chop
it down start taking the wood and making
stuff with it and start selling it just
figure it out you got to start somewhere
you know it's like the Phoenix the
Phoenix was sperm before it can be a new
bird again right that's right yeah all
right everybody we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends and become a member over at
timcast.com click that join us button at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you those go
live around 11 p.m and uh let's uh let's
read a bunch of super chats I know many
people have been chiming in about Mr
bocus and I really really do appreciate
it so uh today at four so here's what
happened for those that are wondering
uh I finished my my 1pm segment and then
as I was putting together a a story
about you know Elon Jet and liberals
fleeing the platform and everything Mr
bocus got up started walking nearly
collapsed Allison my girlfriend ran over
and grabbed him and he had like he'd
like drool coming from his mouth she
brought him to his litter box where he
tried to go in failed and then crapped
on the floor came out and then stumbled
over and he was in really really bad
shape so I was just like there's there's
no way I'm gonna be able to work like
I'm not gonna leave him and go sit at
the computer and so I figured what we'll
do is you know I'll make one last I'll
make one video for him talking about
what's going on and and and Mr bocus
he's the he's the cat of the cast Castle
he's he's appeared behind us he's jumped
in the desk everybody loves him he's
everybody's friend and uh long story
short of it is I made that video because
I didn't want to not give an update and
just disappear and not produce anything
but I also felt like in in 10 20 years I
can come back to my YouTube channel I
can see that video I made and always
remember him and uh I thought that was
important I also think for everybody who
has a pet or any loved one there will
never be a point in my life where I look
back on the final days of Mr boca's life
and I say man I'm so glad I ignored him
and went made a video complaining about
Twitter it's just not that important in
the long run and I'll leave you with one
last story that I think is very
important
I read this on Reddit where a guy said
he was sitting with his brother and his
grandmother and they were looking at her
photo album and she was showing him a
photo of the Grand Canyon and then she
paused she was telling him like I was
here with your your father and your
uncle and then she froze and said
why did I take a picture of the Grand
Canyon I don't care about that I care
about your father and your uncle and he
says from that point from that point on
every time he would go somewhere the
photos would always be of him and his
friends at the place and not of the
place or the thing I thought that was
very very important but let's uh let's
uh let's read some super chats
all right soundscape underground says
you can only accept my five dollars if
your cat gets a viking funeral to
Valhalla yeah Phil I like that idea I
think we should go forward with it and
let's prepare the crossbows I don't know
about a crossbow I think we should get
like a trained Archer and then we should
go to the ocean where it's safe and you
know give Mr Bogus a viking funeral Phil
was like yeah and I'm like I don't know
if something like a dead cat on fire is
legal you know I'm like kicking it out
into a Waterway or something but I think
if we go to a private Marina or
something on the on the water or we just
go out to a totally unincorporated area
and then you know put a little boat
under the water and I'm still I haven't
given up on bucko yet I think
get a stem cells man I think I think I
think we can
I know we can
I I think
regenerative medicine is come a long way
I'm going to do what I gotta do
see if it works
wait if he's in a lot of pain it's hard
to interrupt you man no no no no no I
was right there with you before I you
know before and after I started I've
been trying to hold it together the
whole time
we looked into stem cells the hospital
he was at that's nearby doesn't do it I
looked up a few videos that the issue is
there's a whole bunch of places there's
a bunch of places but there's like not
that many around the country so there's
a guy near San Diego this doctor I'm
gonna shout him out because he does a
lot of good work his name's uh Robert
Harmon he's one of the leading
Veterinary stem cell doctors in the
world Robert if you're out there
we need you I don't know if I can even
write for it but I'm gonna contact you
and let's we'll go from there we'll read
some more of these thoughtful posts uh
really do appreciate everybody
sideways says hey bud I'm really sorry
about bogus but I'm glad he was able to
live a more full life than he could have
otherwise just hope you're doing okay
Tim I'm doing okay it's just you know I
was just as we're building the new
headquarters we're talking like where's
where's where's where's bucko going to
go where's boca's gonna be and I'm like
well we're going to figure out something
for him you know he's he's here in the
studio most the time so everybody always
sees him and he's always you know acting
silly
and he was supposed to be alive for
another 15 years
I mean he's well fed he's well taken
care of we bring him to the vet
periodically but uh cats they hide their
illnesses and so even when we brought
him to the vet a month or so ago they
just said well you know get them get
them different food he seems to be okay
they didn't do the blood work it wasn't
until he started passing out that they
were like holy crap he's on the verge of
death and then even then they said we
think he's got a few a few weeks maybe a
few months and then today I mean this is
he's he's he's been eating he's been
better he like collapsed and could
barely get up so he's been sleeping all
day
well we'll read some more
uh
Raymond g Stanley Jr says behold
unbeknownst to the beautiful bird
sunbathing on a low Branch behind it
bouncing it bounces brandishing beard
claws besieges into action it is the
Beloved baby bunny butcher bucko aka Mr
bocus I was I was I was uh you know
asking Allison I was like should we
should we capture a small bird and
injure it so that Buckle can can kill
one more time
you know it's it's kind of it's kind of
messed up because like we really care
about him but he's just mercilessly
torturing these birds he he he he he
stabbed one and it was bleeding and then
he sat and watched it as it fluttered
and tried to escape and then it never
jumped he would jump and whack it and
knock it back to the ground and I'm like
this is the brutal nature of what he's
doing and here we are mourning for him
he's still alive but he's basically
lethargic and just sleeping all day
so we'll we'll see man we'll see
all right
Jay says have you guys heard about the
idea in the UK about separating cities
into 15-minute driving segments Sky News
Australia was talking about a few days
ago what does that mean
separating cities into 15-minute driving
segments like 15 minutes apart I think
is what they're trying to say oh I see
yeah so so it's in One Direction yeah
yeah that's kind of what you guys like
already isn't it yeah
I guess I mean London is a massive
spattering of people right right but as
soon as you get outside of it near the
countryside it's like it's what it seems
like at least at least in my experience
there it's also
Triton 54 says Miss Allison if you're
listening thank you so much for your
support of Tim during this difficult
time Tim Needs you just as we need him
godspeed Mr bocus Matt from Joliet
Doc Holliday says keep your TDS in check
tonight Luke
what don't you dare don't tell me what
to do one number two
um again when it comes to Trump when he
did something good I respected it called
it out when he did something bad he did
some bad things he got called out for it
as well so uh would anyone you'd never
put anyone above yourself always be
critical of everyone
John Adams says Tim I just finished
watching your tribute to Mr bocus God
bless you and bocus as he makes his way
to the other side
really do appreciate it above all asks
do I watch JoJo's Bizarre Adventure I
don't
you should is it good I think it's great
oh what is it about
um I mean I don't want to spoil for you
but basically it is JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure oh yeah that's literally what
it is it's bizarre you should watch it
though I've seen memes of it it's an
anime yeah yeah that's right it's a
manga anime uh the anime is where it's
at for sure fans know Justin Deboer just
put uh Super Chat three said Tim please
put Mr bocus on one of your Times Square
Billboards oh that'd be cool I want to
um but we'll have to see hey you know he
could he could make it a little while
longer and and if he does I'm not going
to put up a you know memorial for him
when he's still alive we're gonna do we
can for him it's brutal man he's got
genetic defects that's that's just it
he's he's a he's a great cat he's really
nice to everybody he comes up and yells
at you but people can pick him up they
can pet him he's just he'll you'll pick
him up and he'll just flop out and let
you do your thing and you know he's a
good cat and so it's sad that he only
made it to about four years old
C'est La Vie you know it's life I'll say
one more thing too uh
obviously it sucks everybody who's lost
a pet knows it's pain
I'm not gonna equate a cat to a human
life or anything like that there are
some people who are like dude you gotta
grow up and get over it and I'm like
you know like if I wanted to I thought
about this
I could just Zen it out meditate on it
and then just smile and not as as bogus
as flame goes out and and his energy
dissipates into the universe but I
choose to feel it you know like we're
we're all men of action here and I know
that everybody at this table could
choose to bottle uh bottle it up and do
what must be done and plow ahead because
they're there are there are important
jobs to be done important work to be
done but I think you know for me at
least I'm here to live The Human
Experience so uh you know I'll roll with
it Ian you know giving a little tears
out tonight I'm sure you could just shut
it off and and be stoic and cold-faced
but I think it's good to uh sometimes
just let that emotion out you know what
I mean yeah it's part of it's part of
the healing process we talk about like
how can we make people whole again you
know this is one way to do it feel it in
public man
all right
Chrome leader says doxing is a fourth
amendment issue changed my mind is it
I mean people's records are public
that's the challenge yeah the government
doing it I would agree with
yeah
the maladroy maladre mama
yeah oh yeah I do I can't pronounce
these words I'm a local experienced
Barista in WV Panhandle who can I
contact to apply an interview for the
upcoming coffee shop oh man I mean we
definitely do need an experienced
Barista probably a bunch actually for
the new uh location which should be
actually set up in it not not too long
for me I mean
because the holidays it may be January
February but I think we could
theoretically get something up and
running really really quick I mean to be
completely honest we could open the
front door right now with a big banner
that says the name and be like we don't
got anything here yet but you can come
and sit in the chair I mean I'm sure
people would hang out anyway it's
something to do and then we'll slowly
Build It Up over time uh I I don't know
I don't know how you can kind of go to
uh
timcast.com and go to the about or
contact Section and then you can send an
email to somebody and let them know that
you you super chat on the show and
mentioned you're in the area and want to
be a barista and we'll we'll see what we
can do WV I like that all right Rhiannon
tunnel says please tell Mr bocus that
all the viewers of this show love him
and will miss hearing about his
terrorism also should put him in Times
Square on New Year's Eve as a tribute
I believe we can do that I believe we
can
uh let's let's uh let's get some more
super jets they're all basically for Mr
bocus I understand you know I I had to
put out a video
you know Eric Miller says it's a Capcom
game called Remember me where they had
port on the back of their neck and they
would use it to rewrite memories to
manipulate people
yeah that's a crazy thought we get to
the point where we cyberize our brains
and then you can be like I had a really
traumatic experience when I went to that
event
whoop I don't remember going to the
event at all right that's why I brought
up ghostness jokes or it's a ghost in
the show yet when the guy thinks he has
all his memories about like uh his
daughter and all this stuff yeah you
should watch we haven't seen it yep
let's grab some more
Sergeant Buck says Alejandra Caraballo
is the same activist that claims to be
responsible for getting James Lindsay
banned on Twitter and now James
Lindsay's back so too bad
but those people are all just making
things up and lying
Michelle J says Tim get Mr bocus outside
some even so sick yeah we're we're
planning out also the other plan is
we've been looking at a local shelter
we want to bring in Mr bocus to select
an air
who will inherit the title of bocus and
then uh we'll learn from him how to be a
cat
and then at the very least he is unable
to reproduce because they chopped his
balls off
but his ideas can be instilled in the
younger cat and then I was explaining to
Allison the importance of Legacy because
she's just you know she's like bogus
can't have kids that's it what do you
why why are you and your brother so
concerned about Legacy and I'm like
think of it this way
there is an Old World War II veteran who
goes and lives in the woods sits there
with his dog and then dies then there's
the Old World War II veteran sitting on
his porch and a young kid comes up to
him and the old man tells him the
stories of storming the beaches of
saving lives of rescuing these women and
then that kid inspired by those thoughts
grows up and becomes a marine captain or
or something and joins the military and
then serves his country and that's
that's that's the importance that uh Mr
bocus will teach that little kitten some
things and those behaviors will live on
forever
it's sad to me
that uh billions of years of evolution
and cellular development and it all ends
with that one life because we spay and
neutron but I get why we do it I do
that's another reason why I'm so
concerned about how they're sterilizing
kids because it's like billions of years
of evolution ends with you
every single one of your ancestors
succeeded in reproducing yeah
I'm not saying to have 50 kids I mean
you can have one you know
there's going to be a population crash
that's going to go bad it's gonna be bad
I'm saying I mean you'll see you'll see
decades and decades from now Skyler
Hillman says did Mr bocus support free
speech to him he absolutely did
he would he would yell outside the door
cheering us on he'd come in and jump up
on the table it is kind of crazy to
think that it was like a week ago he was
at the door yelling at us yeah and the
decline was just rapid because cats hide
their illnesses and it was only until he
was in total like he's in stage three
renal failure he's passing out were we
like wow and now he's just rapidly
declining so we're giving him IV fluids
we've got medicine for him but I want to
be careful too because they prescribed
prescribed antibiotics but I know
antibiotics can be hard on kidneys and
his kidneys are already weak so we don't
know if he actually even needs the
antibiotics yeah man I'm so concerned
with especially in cancer patients when
they give them chemo and then the chemo
kills them and then they say it was the
cancer like you got to be so careful
with with delicate bodies and just
quality of life is everything right now
for bucko I I don't want him to be in
pain you know I I will do anything to
find a new medicine if that it's real
but at the same time if he's in a lot of
pain you got to let him go
that's the thing you know they want us
to do this IV fluid treatment I really
did help him we gave him some fluids and
he immediately sprang up and so that's
good but I'm also sitting there thinking
like you know if he's dying
are we just prolonging his life for our
own benefit and making him suffer longer
do we let him sleep and be as
comfortable as he can without bothering
him without waking him up without
jamming pills down his throat because
because I really do you know feel like
at a certain point the Pill Popper in
his throat to make him eat the medicine
the needle in his back to give him the
fluids we are just making his last days
worse so that we don't feel as bad but
we still feel bad as it's happening I
bet the fluids were great for him yeah
he sprang right up all excited and they
started acting normal again
and I was thinking about it too it's
been a couple months since he used to
run up and down the hallways like only
six months ago and so his deterioration
has been been happening we could tell
something was wrong but didn't seem that
bad yeah and I wish you know I I wish
we'd we could have caught it uh sooner
all right Geary Vision because we're
we're inter interlacing news with with
bocus Elon wants to make Twitter a video
site but now you can't live stream
newsworthy events such as State of the
Union according to the new doxing rule
well Luke makes that point if you're
going and covering a news event and the
celebrities there are they going to be
like oh you showed the real-time
location of these people yeah that's
but I don't know man I I think there can
be judgment in how it's done like
obviously if you're doing a broadcast
what is it uh like obviously you're
doing a broadcast you're not doxing
someone obviously if you're posting
someone's private you know jet
information you are you know so there's
a difference
and then bad things can happen
Weber Jay says hey Tim tried to watch
the 4 P.M segment lasts about four
minutes and had to stop tears started
flowing felt for you you're a good dude
amen I really appreciate it it was very
hard to make
but uh it was a combination of me being
like I hate not
talking about something and putting
something out and I always say that I
just want to talk about what I feel like
talking about and today it was Mr bocus
and in 15 20 years I'm going to be an
old man and I'm gonna show my kids I'm
gonna be like take a look at this video
you know when when they have a sad day
with with our pet when we're old and you
know they're young teenagers and the
dogs dying or whatever I'll be like
watch this video of me when I was
younger and I think that's that's really
great and he was laying on the table and
we were petting him the whole time
all right steamed hams says I love your
work to him I also love how you get
people from different political spheres
and careers is there any chance of
trying to get Destiny on the show he yes
is a great online debater we've had him
on the show uh we'd love to have him
back on the show I think Destiny's great
actually
um we disagreed it was funny when he
came I was like Destiny I think you and
I are going to agree on basically
everything and he was like what and then
we disagreed on some things like
wokeness we disagreed on some things
like Crisis management but a lot of it
is you know disagreeing on the on how to
get to places but agreeing on the on the
on the end goals plus I mean Destiny's
you know he's he's I think he's like a
fairly liberal guy but he's also the guy
who got suspended on Twitch for saying
Kyle rittenhouse's the video was the
clearest cut case of self-defense he's
ever seen they got really mad at him for
that so he's a cool dude we'd love to
have him back on it be fun
all right
corn says thank you for your kind words
when my dog past may offer the same kind
words to you the tears shed for bocus
are a testament to his impact
yeah it's not the same you know we love
Mr bocus I'm a dog person well shout out
to Beau whoever that was that tweeted
you a picture of Bo a couple days ago
you responded with a heart icon oh yeah
Beau the dog okay thinking a lot about
you Bo if you're out there you are out
there man it's crazy I was reading this
Meme and it said
to to to dogs and to cats but it was
like to dogs we are these tall beings of
tremendous magical powers we can make
images appear we can cure diseases we
can create we make wonderful meals and
food we can travel it ultra high speeds
and we live ten lifetimes of a dog we're
basically like elves yeah yeah
magic powers shoot water out of tubes
imagine what it would be like to be like
living in a place where these beings
they live for a thousand years they fly
around they can do whatever and we're
just like man that's what it's like for
dogs and cats you know
let's grab this one what do we got
Chris page says Banks lost trillions and
must find the money before January 1st
then four major crypto Founders have
been found dead FTX founder has jailed
connection
Maybe
those stories are creepy I feel like Sam
bankman free was jailed for a lot of
reasons other than just the banks with
money he was jailed right before he was
supposed to testify that's not that's so
strange that's something weird that's
something that obviously I I think
stinks to high heaven I didn't know
about that yeah he's gonna he was gonna
go before Congress and then all of a
sudden they're like nope nope nope
arrest them you would want more
information you would want if you're a
prosecutor I mean correct me if I'm
wrong you would want him to Spill the
Beans be in front of a congressional
committee get as much information as you
can and then charge him why would you
stop his testimony were they just
getting testimony to see if that was
ammunition those ammunition to to of
course uh you know have a more
successful case against him I bet they
officially felt like they had enough
because uh the doj went charged him
um there were three different
organizations that charged him in the
government and it was like for nine
counts of fraud all these just I mean
there's
anyway tentacled uh vesicle says cats
are natural anarchists they actually are
yeah yep that's right dogs are more like
soldiers you know
loyal they trust you they trust they
trust the chain of command well not all
dogs some dogs are wild you know and and
Untamed but a good dog they trust the
chain of command you know and then uh
they're they're there for you and you're
there for them that's the point
all right I love Max says I just had to
put my cat Max to sleep a few days ago
he couldn't walk and he was a hunter I
hope Mr bocus can recover I feel your
pain the boat Mr Boca saw four doctors
and they all said he can't recover and
they're actually surprised he lasted
this long and uh he's a strong little
dude the cardiac uh the the cardio uh
what's the word for cardiologist I guess
the cardiovascular doctor said he's got
a problem with his heart he's had
clearly for a while it's genetic
developmental the uh the emergency
doctor said his kidneys are
underdeveloped so it's probably why it
happened so so such a young age the
treatment for his heart problem is
counter-indicated for his kidney problem
so trying to treat both
it just they harm each other and so they
were like basically we want to give them
palliative care Hospice Care to improve
his quality of life in his in his last
few days and she said I'm really sorry
but I really do hope he makes it to
Christmas
so I guess the big challenge for us is
we're flying on Saturday to Turning
Point USA for their their am fest to do
the show on stage which is going to be
really really epic and there there
really are some some challenges that I
thought about so I'll wrap up with this
final thought
you know some people have said no no Tim
you you know this is the line stay home
stay with Mr bocus and I'm like
if it was a family member perhaps as
much as I love Mr bocus I also recognize
my responsibility to humanity and not to
my own selfish desires to spend time
with an animal that I love
so I do want to spend as much time as
possible with him make my tribute video
for him get him the treatment he needs
but at a certain point I have to live my
life and I have to keep it my
responsibilities to all of you and that
is if we have an opportunity to spread
good ideas and help people and make the
world a better place and we can do it to
a great degree with turning point in
Phoenix at this massive event with 10
000 plus people that really matters and
I you know we'll spend as much time as I
can with Mr bocus and then we'll come
back and hopefully I believe we will
have him for Christmas and it won't it
won't be the end I mean they said maybe
two months so we're gonna we're gonna
assume two months but if his time comes
as time comes and uh as much as he is a
cat that we love and we do we'd be
willing to spend whatever it took to
save him
we have responsibilities to humanity as
well so you know I don't want to
I I was thinking about
if there was a a
sergeant or a commanding officer and
he's with his unit and they're in the
middle of a conflict and then he finds
out that someone you know felon got hurt
and they're dying and he says I'm going
to leave the group I've got to go see
them this is more important like no
that's devastating for everybody else so
you can't you can't abandon your post
even you know
so I think going going to the event is
is is important and also there are a lot
of people here who love him who want to
be with him as well and will take care
of him so it's just a hard reality I
could I could shut down the next few
weeks of my life because Mr bocus
unexpectedly took a turn for the worse
or we can do our best for him I can
spend as much time with him and then you
know we both live our lives so yeah I
agree with you I I thought that my own
grief was selfish and it is in a little
way but like why is why is me dealing
with like there's so much more out there
you listening your your grief like I
don't want to waste your time with mine
it's important that we grieve together
but there's a bigger a bigger story
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com because we have a
couple stories they're just actually
kind of awful so after that heartfelt
tug on your heartstrings we're going to
talk about how nasty things kind of are
because Joe Biden's coming out and
defending you know uh grooming and other
horrible things we'll talk about that
you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me personally at timcast
uh Gene you want to shout anything out
I'd look I just I really appreciate the
opportunity to be here and I think you
have a stellar audience I think you guys
are really onto something and I think
there's some real opportunities for
Freedom loving Americans as we as we
progress into the future
where can people find you what's your
Twitter account
so you can find me at uh America First
legal but it's america1st legal and also
at
www.aflegal.org so I that's that is
where we are that is where I am WE Post
every everything that we do all of our
work there
um and uh encourage everyone to go check
it out it's uh it's a good time Gene
thank you so much for coming on that was
a great conversation my website is Luke
uncensored.com where I made a video
about a very similar topic about how you
should cherish your pets and your family
I did a video that was titled this is
how you actually help your family first
and it kind of goes off the conversation
that we had yesterday when it came to of
course Very tumultuous political
conversations at the dinner table
there's ways of achieving these
conversations and getting your family on
board helping them out and working
together to be the best strongest
versions of yourselves family is more
important than ever Lucan sensor.com see
you there for that conversation as well
as the conversation in the Forum where
we are giving out prizes as well uh Ian
Crossing you can follow media
crosston.net but really go check out
Luke's video on putting family first
that's important and if you didn't see
Tim talking about bucko with bucko and
Allison it's a it's a video's worth
watching it's a great cat
I'm talking about you homie bucko's a
good cat too
bye guys
and I'd like to shout out Kellen
speaking of uh people you appreciate
Kellen PDL at Kellen PDL he'll be taking
over for the next couple days here while
I fly out to Phoenix and get everything
ready for the show in Phoenix for uh
amfest it'll be fun it's going to be
really interesting because we're doing
the show live on stage at TP USA with
some high profile people who probably
will say very spicy things so I'm like
I'm ready for it you know look this is a
massive event it is what it is all right
everybody head over to timcast.com we're
gonna have that members only show coming
up for you in about 45 minutes or so
click the join us button on timcast.com
when you do you'll also see a picture of
Mr bocus he is front and center in our
little Talent roster thanks for hanging
out and we'll see y'all there cheers